und abos verdient hat das ist auch aber so ein channel der in
deutschland niemals erfolgreich wäre nie das ist einfach im deutschen
let's player reacting land nicht angesagt im deutschen reacting
glücksspiel land youtube deutschland ist eine mischung aus
irgendwelchen merkwürdigen let's plays von leuten die teilweise gar nicht
spielen können die ich muss ja sagen ich jetzt schon
bedenken bedenklich dass ich das jetzt sagen muss aber die einzigen leute auf
youtube in deutschland die halbwegs spielen können sind die fortnight leute
der rest ist reaction und irgendwelche komischen
glücksspiel poker box openings sonst was dinger
aber das muss man sagen dass das übelst nahe ist
das war der absichtlich gemacht oder das hat die russische die russische
nationalhymne einfach mal bei uk reingeschnitten hat
united kingdom
ich finde die lustig
science youtuber such as tom scott dr stelle page steve mault be
clive
der fast jedes mal die steckdose
videos so
und du solltest du führer riemer uk makes up around five and a half percent
of my viewers right after germany and united states and i've heard a lot about
how safe their plugs and outlets are i'm going to go there and test them a little
ich habe ich habe noch nie in den uk stecker doch ich hatte schon in uk
stecker in der hand von meinem headset das kam aus uk und hat einen adapter dabei gehabt
aber ich habe noch nie in den uk stecker in die
security was very suspicious do i want something to find the proper adapter to
convert my not so als kann ich euch sagen wenn man wenn man das ist das eher
ein trolling kanal nähe gar nicht das ist ich sage ja das ist ein kanal der
würde in der welt in deutschland nicht erfolgreich das ist lustig einfach weil
es gut gemacht ist und er hat teilweise mit die besten erklärungen so außen
Elektronikbereich, die ich kenne.
Der Typ, der ist überhaupt nicht...
Jetzt müsst ihr mal mehr Videos sagen.
Ich finde den überhaupt nicht unsympathisch.
Der ist übelst nice.
Aber eins kann ich euch sagen.
Dieser komische Adapter wird das Video garantiert nicht überleben, so wie ich den kenne.
War jemand schon mal in London, dass das Wetter wirklich so kacke ist?
Also der Kram wird das Video nicht überleben.
Das Erste ist natürlich mal den Sicherungsschalter im Hotelzimmer suchen.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Mir fällt kein Hotelzimmer ein, wo ich jemals einen Sicherungsschalter drin gesehen hätte.
Vielleicht ist es in einem zentralen elektrischen Raum irgendwo.
Ich muss besser keine Shorts machen.
Eines der interessanten Dinge über diese balken britischen Plugs ist,
dass sie, wie ihre nordamerikanischen Voraussetzungen,
die Metall komplett auf den Live-Pronzen ausgeschlossen haben,
halb so viel Plastik haben.
Also wenn es halbwegs inseriert ist und Kontakt zu Live-Weiren macht,
ist nur Plastik ausgeschlossen.
Also ist es sicherer.
Ich meine, es ist etwas, was getestet wird.
Ich habe diesen Adapter hier in den UK gekauft,
mit ordentlichem Boden und Füßen und allem.
Und wenn ihr hier schaut,
habe ich zwischen den beiden Prongen mit einem dünnen Stück Leitfaden.
Jetzt, wenn ich ihn einpucke,
wenn es Kontakt macht,
während diese Metalle ausgeschlossen sind,
wird dieses Ding öffnen und ich weiß es.
Andererseits, wenn ich es weiter einpucke,
wird es dieses Stück Leitfaden zurückpuckeln
und nichts passiert und ich weiß, dass es sicher ist.
Okay, es ist definitiv gesperrt.
Lass uns ihn einpuckeln.
Hoffentlich wird nichts passieren und ich weiß es.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Haha, das war klar.
Oh, jezu.
Wow.
Das ist so geil.
Vor allem erst mal im Hotel das Ding abgefackelt, ey.
Ich muss es besser abschließen, bevor sie es sehen.
Nun, ich bin im Grunde genommen weggeflogen.
Der Verbrecher für alle Raum-Outlets ist gerade aufgefallen.
Und ich kann es nicht abschließen,
also muss das Hotel das für mich reparieren.
Lass mal kurz abhauen, bis das Zeug wieder funktioniert.
Wupp, Wupp-S.
Wir haben ein extra Smoke-Emote, Leute.
Das fällt mir gerade ein.
Diese Lichter fliegen auf Gas.
Global Warming, Mann.
Benutze LED.
Das Hotel hat den Verbrecher gespeichert.
Und eine Sache ist sicher.
Dieser Schalter ist...
Und das Hotel hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht,
warum ist unsere Sicherung rausgeflogen.
...ein nur redundantes Zeug.
Es ist ein Schalter, nicht ein Verbrecher.
Und wenn man sich hier anschaut,
muss der Schalter ziemlich tief gehen,
bevor man einen Kontakt macht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum mein Test verfehlt wurde,
oder warum ich es so gemacht habe,
während ich es so machen konnte.
Vielleicht wurde mein Schalter hier
in den Socket gedrängt,
anstatt wegzuschalten.
Also ist es immer noch sicherer,
ohne live-Werte auszuschalten.
Was ich auch nicht kalkuliert habe, war, dass...
Hm?
Hey, es gibt kleine Türen auf diesen Outlets,
damit man nichts reinstecken kann.
Das ist doch gut.
Der Grundprang muss zuerst rein,
um diese Türen zu entlocken.
Ah, das ist mal Big Brain.
Wir haben einen 240 Volt AC,
50 Hertz hier in den USA.
Zurück in 120 Volt AC Kanada
würde mein dünnes Zeug
zuerst vor jedem Verbrecher kommen.
Weil jedes ähnliche Haus
auf der ganzen Welt
die gleiche Kraft zieht.
Wie eine 100 Watt Lampe
ist 100 Watt wo auch immer.
Also sind Dinge...
Ich triggere das immer,
wenn alle aus NA
anstatt Watt-Watts sagen.
Was hat das S da hinten dran zu suchen?
Das sagt dir aber auch keiner.
Du sagst ja auch nicht...
Zwei...
Keine Ahnung...
KMHS...
Ja, Moment.
Das S bei...
Das halt...
Das S da steht ja auch für Sekunde.
Bei Watts steht das S
definitiv nicht für Sekunde.
Watt pro Sekunde
ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Weil Watt ist schon pro Sekunde.
Also...
Schon in Watt drinne ist das.
Uhu...
Curiosity Stream,
der Sponsor dieses Videos.
Curiosity Stream.
Die beste Sorge über 2400
wunderschön gemachte
Wissen und Wissenschaftsdokumentare,
auch exklusive Originals.
Was ist Energie pro Sekunde?
Also ist...
ist Energie pro Sekunde
pro Sekunde
übelst beknackt?
...Electro Boom
auf der Checkout.
Du bekommst den ganzen Monat
voller Zugang
für Freunde,
Freunde,
Sekunde oder so.
Ist ja immer schlimmer.
Ja, es gibt Kilo...
Es gibt... Das gibt es.
Allerdings ist das mal...
Mal Kilowatt mal Zeit.
Nicht durch Zeit.
KWS wird es geben. Das sind dann Kilowattstunden
mal Sekunde.
Aber, ähm,
das wäre ganz schön viel.
Ja.
Das ist...
KWH ist eine Energiemenge im Endeffekt.
Ja,
Chat ist wieder richtig
Big Brain heute.
Es haben zu wenig Leute gesubbt.
Der IQ ist zu niedrig noch.
Er steigt erst mit ein paar
Subs.
Ja, wenigstens haben wir
einen Elektroniker hier am Start.
Wobei Watt auch, also gibt es ja
verschiedene Grundlagen.
Joule pro Sekunde, beziehungsweise Energie pro Sekunde.
Deswegen ist es noch
beknackter zu sagen
Watt pro Sekunde.
Das ist dann Energie pro Sekunde.
Wie das steigt oder so.
Keine Ahnung, es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Also meine Lieblings-Bullshit-Einheit ist das hier.
BTU
Stunde.
Oder BTU pro Stunde.
Das ist meine Lieblings-Bullshit-Einheit.
Wisst ihr was das ist?
Das wird bei manchen USVs verwendet.
Das ist British Thermal Unit
pro Stunde.
Das heißt,
ähm,
Ähm, British Thermal Unit ist eine Einheit, wie viel Energie es braucht, das ist so Best-of-Bullshit-Einheiten,
wie viel Energie es braucht, ein, ich glaube, ein Pfund, irgendwie ein Pfund Wasser um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erzeugen.
Das ist übelster Bullshit, ey.
Dass sowas überhaupt noch heute verwendet wird.
Überlegt euch mal, das ist so definiert, als wäre man die Bühne.
Ein britisches Pfund Wasser um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erweilen.
Warum verwendet man sowas 2019 noch?
Was ist das?
Alter, was ist mit denen nicht richtig im Kopf?
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das nochmal an, was wir eben drüber geredet haben.
Was ich meine ist das hier.
Ein Joule pro Sekunde.
So, und bei elektronischem Zeug ist es relativ simpel.
Dann ist es Volt mal Ampere.
Wobei es nicht so einfach ist, aber...
Wie gesagt, ich bin auch kein krasser Elektrotechnik-Kurs.
Können wir einfach das Video weiter schauen.
Aber das ist wirklich eine Kackeinheit, ey.
Das ist eine richtig...
Auch für kühlende Geräte von Rechenzentren wird die in Abwärme abgegeben für Luxor, in BTU.
Sowas beknacktes, bei USVs auch.
Bei USV steht dann BTU pro Stunde drauf.
Wir gucken, wir müssen uns jetzt den Sellout von ihm angucken.
Wenn wir schon sein Video gucken, gucken wir uns auch den Sellout an.
Wie 20 Dollar pro Jahr.
Für den lieben Gott, verliere nicht diese Promotion.
Hier ist es offen.
Und eine Sache ist sicher.
Wenn du auf diese Plugge steckst,
möge Gott dir die Gnade an der Seele geben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Zuerst, alle diese Plugge haben eine Füße, die in ihnen hergestellt wird.
Eine 13 Ampere in diesem Fall.
Was, wenn etwas...
Oder?
Nee, oder?
Nie gesehen.
Wenn etwas in deinem Gerät steckt, wird es öffnen, was für ein viel weniger interessantes Video ist.
Und du siehst hier, das längste Gerät ist das Grundgerät mit etwas Schlag und das Gerät-Test ist das Live-Gerät.
Also, wenn das Gerät ausgelöst wird, ist das Live-Gerät das erste, was von deinem Gerät ausgelöst wird.
Ich find's ja schon mal interessant, dass er in seinem Hotelzimmer erstmal alle Lampen aufschraubt und sich das anguckt, ja?
Was viel sicherer ist.
Also, diese Plugge haben viel mehr Sicherheitsmöglichkeiten.
Im Vergleich zu ihren nordamerikanischen Gegnern.
Ich werde die GFCI- oder RCD-Schläge in ihrem Hotel nicht testen.
Ich bin schon überrascht, dass ich einmal ihre Schläge aufgeschraubt habe.
Ich warte, bis ich zu meinem Cousins Haus komme.
Das London Museum.
Wow, schau dir das an.
Diese Dinger sind in der Luft.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was sie damit verwendet haben, um das zu kühlen.
Es könnte ein Peltier-Gerät sein oder so.
Ich mag diese...
...fliegende Lampen.
Ups. Wie kannst du sie zurückziehen?
Oh, ich habe einen Sub übersehen.
Den haben wir hier.
Ähm...
TheUnde. Dankeschön. Twitch Prime.
Pog.
N-n-nice...
...Subscriber.
Huge Sub.
Okay, du hast es versucht.
Nicht einfach, oder?
Ah, da ist er.
Und die LEDs sind auch elektrisch gestärkt.
Oh, verdammt.
Willkommen in Cambridge.
In meinem Cousins Haus.
Und schau dir das an, was ich in ihrem Kabel gefunden habe.
Sie haben eigentlich eine Brecherbox hier unten.
Macht ihr das nicht auch immer, wenn ihr irgendwo zu Gast seid?
Das erste, was ihr sucht, ist erstmal den Sicherungskasten?
Das sollte jeder so machen.
Erstmal, wenn man neu in irgendeinem Haus ist, erstmal den Sicherungskasten suchen.
Zwei Set, für irgendeinen Grund.
Und jedes Set hat einen RCD.
Oder was heißt das?
Der Residual Current Detector.
Der ist das Gleiche wie der GFCI, den wir in Nordamerika haben.
Aber der Unterschied hier ist, dass der RCD für das gesamte Haus ist,
anstatt für den Nordamerikanischen GFCI, der nur im Wohnzimmer ist.
Der GFCI und der RCD sind beide dafür, den Live Wire Current zu detektieren,
der in die Erde geht, anstatt neutral.
Und die öffnen sich.
Und das lustige ist, dass ihr Socket hier eine andere Form hat,
damit ihr hier das normale Hauswerk nicht verbinden könnt.
Und das ist nur für Schäber.
Und natürlich benötigt ihr keinen GFCI hier,
weil der ganze Haus wird von RCD geschützt.
Nun, sie haben sich selbst geschützt,
um das falsche Material in diesen Socket zu befüllen.
Aber die Nordamerikanischen Socket
füllen diese Sockets,
was bedeutet, dass Touristen wie ich hier etwas befüllen können
und wahrscheinlich etwas öffnen können.
Obwohl ich gehört habe, dass diese Outlets
ihren eigenen internen Fusen
in der Wälder mit viel weniger Current betrachten,
sodass es viel einfacher wird, um zu schießen.
Schäfer's Outlet? Keine Ahnung, ja.
Seht ihr, dass irgendein Device das Current von Live zurückbringt und neutral wird?
Es ist unerwartet und der RCD oder GFCI wird öffnen.
Und der normale Fall ist, dass ein Benutzer,
der mit dem Boden in Kontakt ist,
die Live-Wire ungekloppt hat und geschockt wird.
Also treten diese Dinge meistens
bei viel weniger Current, um die Person zu schützen.
Well, first things first.
Zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Pock.
Für die guten Prime-Flows, ja.
Nice, dankeschön.
Prime. S-S-Samscrimer, ne?
First, what does it take to trip the RCD?
Fabulous Muffin, Twitch Prime.
Prime.
Nice.
Dankeschön.
Nice, jetzt geht's ja ab, ja.
Schlag auf Schlag.
I connected my North American wires to the adapter and let's measure.
Oh, interesting.
Wie er einfach mal auf dem Boden
irgendwelche Kabel liegen hat, direkt aus der Steckdose.
Das ist...
Das wirkt ein bisschen, äh...
Das ist ein bisschen so, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, er ist das ja gewohnt, ja.
Neutral connections are flipped here, so now white is live wire.
I brought a bunch of different resistors.
I brought a bunch of different resistor values to put between live and earth and see which one will trip the RCD.
North American GFCI trips at around 5 milliamps, so let's try a 47 kilo and see if it trips the RCD.
Das war klar, ey.
Never use your bare hands.
Oh, f***.
What did I pop?
Let's just be careful, okay?
47k between live and earth.
I didn't pop anything.
10k.
Iced tea.
2 monate, dankeschön.
Samus Climber.
Wer nimmt keine Widerstände mit in den Urlaub?
Ne gute Frage, ja.
Ja, so ne kleine Kiste mit den wichtigsten Widerständen sollte man schon immer mal dabei haben, ne?
Ein paar Raspberry Pis können auch nix schaden.
Wer weiß, was man im Urlaub alles so braucht.
Der Typ hat Videos, die gra...
Ich weiß, weiss.
Okay.
Oh, there you go, we popped the RCD.
Ich guck alle Videos von dem, ich find den so geil.
Und dann hab ich ihn gepoppt.
How do you unpop this thing?
Oh, there you go.
You just need extra force.
14.7k.
Nope.
12k.
There you go.
This means that the RCD trips at around 20 milliamps, which is a much stronger shock compared to the 5 milliamp of the GFCI.
But on the bright side, the whole house is protected by the RCD.
Now, what will happen if we plug things that are meant for 120V AC into 240V?
Und drauf an. Die meisten gehen kaputt.
Things like resistive bulbs such as incandescent light bulbs or inductive loads like motors will draw double the current, so quadruple the power.
So those will blow up.
But switching power supplies such as a battery charger or a laptop wall adapter are designed to work on 100V to 240V AC.
So nothing will happen to these and they will draw half the current from the power lines compared to 120V.
But on transformer-based wall adapters such as this one,
the output of the transformer is not regulated, so on 240V AC it outputs double the voltage.
So if you use this to power your devices, they will blow up, although nothing should happen to the transformer itself.
Ja, bestimmt.
War klar.
Of course, these wall adapters have components that might not be rated for double the voltage.
You can do it!
Serious Max ist da, moin.
Let's go to the next one.
I'm back.
So, UK plugs are fused.
Live wire disconnects first when pulled and no exposed live voltage on prongs.
The outlets can be turned off and the whole house is protected by RCD.
Things we don't have in North America.
I know some people that could have been saved by just the RCD.
The rest of the protections sound kind of redundant, which is pretty important in safety-critical systems.
But hey, in North America, who cares about redundancy?
So thanks to CuriosityStream for sponsoring this video.
So, was gucken wir denn als nächstes?
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten heute?
Ich muss ein neues Tab aufmachen für YouTube, weil ich will nichts leaken von meinem Amazon-Account.
Wonka Leak.
Irgendwann hier empfohlen.
Irgendwie nichts sonderliches.
Installing Windows 98 on a modern laptop.
Na ja, soll ja großartig passieren.
So.
Wird wahrscheinlich installieren, aber keine Hardware funktionieren.
Klar kannst du einen Laptop an den Bahnsteckdosen laden.
Irgendwie nichts von Empfehlung dabei.
Dann muss ich meine Playlist gucken.
Haben wir ansonsten auch hier so.
Ach, wisst ihr, was ich jetzt gesehen hab?
Es gibt jetzt.
Das ist übelst cringe.
Ne?
Es gibt jetzt.
Hab ich heute Morgen auf Twitter gelesen.
Es gibt jetzt auf der CSU.
Gibt es jetzt...
ein.
wie nennt man das
ein Format
für die zukünftigen
jungen, jüngeren Wähler
womit man sie ansprechen möchte
nennt sich CSU
klingt schon übel
und was
echt extrem fail ist
das einzige
wo es das Video gibt ist Facebook
wer verwendet bitte schon
und jetzt
die Abschaffung des Soli
auf den Weg gebracht
wenn also mal wieder jemand in eurem Umfeld
die große Meckerei
über die Politik in Berlin anstimmt
schickt ihm doch einfach einen Link
zu diesem Video
die GroKo liefert
Soldat ist kein Job wie
ich sag mal so
zum Thema Koalitionsvertrag
erinnert sich
noch jemand an
Artikel
13 und solche Dinger
und Online
und irgendwelche
wie heißt es jetzt
Uploadfilter
erinnert sich da noch jemand dran
zufällig
ich weiß ist schon wieder ein halbes Jahr her
was unter anderem da drin steht
dass man das nicht macht
egal das ist wurscht
aber die Aussage hier ist auch geil oder
pass mal wo war das
jetzt die Abschaffung des Soli
auf den Weg gebracht
wenn also mal wieder jemand in eurem Umfeld
in eurem Umfeld
Moment
War das nicht eh geplant
den Soli abzuschaffeln
unabhängig davon
Egal
Zumindest das was jetzt kommt
finde ich ganz interessant
In eurem Umfeld
die große Meckerei
über die Politik in Berlin anstimmt
schickt ihm doch einfach einen Link
zu diesem Video
die GroKo liefert
Moment
In eurem Umfeld
die
Warte mal
wo kam das denn jetzt
mit den zwei Dritteln
Ab Soli gebracht
wenn also mal wieder jemand
fragt
teilweise
oder vollständig
umgebracht
Ach hier
in eurem Umfeld
Zwei Drittel
der Versch...
Pass mal auf
Zwei Drittel
Versprechungen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
teilweise
oder vollständig
Teilweise
Zwei Drittel
teilweise
oder vollständig
Das heißt
im Endeffekt
nichts anderes
auf ein Drittel
scheißt man komplett
Ja
Also ein Drittel
juckt keine Sau
was sie in den Vertrag
reingeschrieben haben
und zwei Drittel
arbeiten sie gerade dran
und ein paar wenige Punkte
davon
haben sie schon
umgeschlossen
Das sagt ja überhaupt
Null aus
Ja
vollständig
umgesetzt
Wenn also mal wieder
jemand in eurem Umfeld
die große Meckerei
über die Politik
in Berlin anstimmt
schickt ihm doch einfach
einen Link
zu diesem Video
die GroKo
liefert
Oh Mann
Soldat ist kein Job
wie jeder andere
und wir wollen
das besonders würdigen
Am 1. Januar 2020
geht's los
Freie Fahrt
Soldat ist kein Job
und ist in der
Uniform in Nah- und Fernverkehr
Jetzt haben uns die Grünen gefragt
warum waren an den Verhandlungen dazu
eigentlich nur die CSU beteiligt?
Ja, warum denn wohl?
Wann habt ihr jemals was für die Bundeswehr getan?
Genau
Noch nie
Wann habt ihr jemals was für die Bundeswehr getan?
Ich hab verweigert
Das reicht
Hab ich genug für die Bundeswehr getan
Aber wenn ihr eure Meinung jetzt geändert habt
Bitte
Ihr seid immer willkommen
Oh yeah
So, das war's für heute
Ich sag vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen
Like, kommentiert und teilt das Video
Like, subscribe, share
Das hat er schon mal raus, der Armin
Das kann er
Ganz liebe Grüße gehen nach Brandenburg und Sachsen
Denn am Sonntag nicht vergessen
Tatort schauen
Servus
Also ehrlich gesagt, Leute, ich muss sagen
Es war weniger cringe als gedacht
Also ehrlich gesagt, Leute, ich muss sagen, es war weniger cringe als gedacht
Leidung hatte ich am Anfang schon, das hat sich jetzt bestätigt
Ich meine, es ist viel Bullshit gelabert im Endeffekt
Tatort schauen
Ich meine, es ist viel Bullshit gelabert
Aber es ist okay, ja
Also es gibt deutlich schlechter produziertere Sachen
Von Leuten, die halt hip sein wollen
Wie kann man Comments lesen jetzt dazu?
Ah, jetzt hier
Comments
Okay, was schreiben wir?
Super tolles Format!
Gefällt mir sehr gut
Sehr gut
Sehr gut gemacht, super
Kurz, knapp, prägnant
Kann man dieses Kack-Facebook-Ding hier unten eigentlich ausblenden?
Gefällt mir
Guter Ansatz
Der Facebook pisst dich alle
Sehr sehr sehr gut, bitte weiter
Wir brauchen mehr davon
Grundsätzlich ja ganz cool
Jetzt kommen so viel Zeug
Wenn das eure Strategie für cooler weiblicher Junge ist, dann gute Nacht
Ich meine cooler als jetzt, aufjeden Fall
Ich meine viengger cool geht eigentlich gar nicht
Ich meine cooler als jetzt aufjedenfall
Ich meine weniger cool geht eigentlich gar nicht
Ähm, jünger...
Na ja gut wir haben żEmindes einen hingestellt der keine 60 plus ist
Ja gut wir haben żEmindes einen hingestellt der keine 60 plus ist
Na ja gut wir haben зовinndes einen hingestellt der keine 60 plus ist
Na ja gut wir haben итunmal was
Und es muss nicht alles auf Teufel kommen raùs weiblicher sein
ich meine nur weil sie einen männlichen Moderator hingestellt haben
weil sie einen hatten ist das ja nicht automatisch gleich Bullshit
Weil sie einen hatten ist das ja nicht automatisch gleich Bullshit
Ich mein das ganze Video war schonst biblioteklos
Also ich vergesst nicht und beschreif mich gar nicht
bisschen gewollt und nicht gekonnt, ja, aber es war nicht so cringe, wie ich mir das vorgestellt
habe, na gut, ja, ich fände es aber ehrlich gesagt cool, wenn andere Parteien auch sowas
in der Richtung machen, so quasi, wer gewinnt den cringe war, und dann sinnlos Greta und
Grün bashing zu machen, ist doch sinnlos, ist doch ein Witz, na warum, die bashen sich
auch alle gegenseitig, also wenn ich ein Video machen würde, als Partei, dann würde ich
meine Gegner auch bashen, warum soll ich meine Gegner nicht bashen, das ist ja gerade
Sinn und Zweck der Videos, es geht ja nicht darum, irgendwie was zu machen, was den Leuten
nützt, es geht darum, gewählt zu werden, und das macht man am besten, leider, indem
man seine Gegner basht, und nicht indem man was Gescheites macht, was schon an sich beknackt
ist, aber Gegner bashen, als würde die irgendwas Klimamäßiges interessieren, das Einzige,
was sie interessiert, ist, dass die Leute sie wählen, das System.
Und wenn man gewählt werden will, reicht es auch, wenn man einfach so tut, als ob, es
müssen bloß genug Leute glauben, dann kann man Fenster nicht resizen, das geht mir echt
auf den Sack, so, in welcher Bitrate streamst du, ich glaube 4, 4 Mbit gerade, aber auf dem
Desktop ist das ja kein Ding, das ist ja, da ist das ja alles datisch, so, also okay,
wir kriegen keine gescheiten Videos empfohlen, da muss ich jetzt mal ein Video aus meiner
Playlist raussuchen.
Und wir gucken uns wieder, ich guck, ich guck diese, diese, ich guck gerne diese Videos,
wo die Leute, das haben wir uns ja, haben wir uns ja jedes, jeden Sonntag mindestens einen
angeguckt, so diese Videos, wo die Leute irgendwelche alten PCs restauren, ich guck das einfach
unglaublich gern, so oller, oller Mist.
Wieso hast du im Zoom einen 200% auf YouTube, damit ich, oh, das klingt sogar nach einem
interessanten Thema, oh, Diablo war's completely reverse engineered without source code, damit
das Video hier im Fullscreen ist.
Dass das Video im Kino, Kino Mode im Fullscreen ist, dass ich nicht Fullscreen machen muss.
Deswegen, ja, da gucken wir uns das an, klingt sogar ganz interessant.
Von dem haben wir schon ein paar Sachen geguckt, der ist ganz gut.
How many times over the last ten years, when we talk about a port of Final Fantasy 8 or
Parasite Eve to modern consoles, that it was not possible due to lost source?
Source code is fundamental code.
Richtig.
When I heard about .emu finally remastering Final Fantasy 8, it poses questions.
How do you exactly lose source code and how is it even possible to reconstruct a game
without source code?
There's tons of speculation surrounding Final Fantasy 8 that the code appeared on some
long lost backup tape or cd
somewhere, but the chances of that are
quite slim. It was well known
that in the 90s, Square did
not use any form of version control
at all, and likely threw out
old hardware complete with the copies of the source
code. Over time, the
code was lost and forgotten.
Ich meine, die hatten ja damals, damals war es ja
noch nicht so, dass du irgendwie ein Software, dass du irgendwie ein Git
oder sowas hattest, also ganz früher,
die Leute hatten quasi irgendwie einen Fileserver
oder sowas und haben da ihr Sourcecode drauf kopiert.
Und dann ist der Fileserver verreckt und das
auskommt von weg.
Warum sollte man auch, warum sollte man auch eine Backup machen,
ne? Komplett overrated.
Äh, Beatport, das ist, äh,
hab ich mir angeguckt, das ist nicht so einfach,
du brauchst ja noch die ganzen Texturen und Sachen,
die sind ja alle nicht dabei.
Unless the company had a good off-site
backup strategy, there were elevated
risks. Failing
hardware is always a threat,
and without safeguards such as modern
cloud-based version control, it can
be catastrophic.
Now, I think it's fair to say
that .mu and Square Enix
have been reversing Final Fantasy
8, or at least consulting with
someone that has been reversing
the game. There are many different
open-source efforts to reverse
engineer Final Fantasy 8,
and they are all in various states of
completion. So the takeaway is, it's
not an insurmountable problem to
overcome, it just takes time.
One thing we
can't rule out about Final Fantasy
8 is that crucial information was
left inside the game to make the job of
reverse engineering easier.
Like lost source code, this happened
more than you think.
One of the
biggest video game releases of 1996
was Blizzard North,
the first action RPG, Diablo.
Diablo was the vision of David Brevik,
who at the time was a lead developer
for Condor Games.
Condor had developed Justice League Task Force,
a fighting game that was produced by
Sunsoft and released for the Sega Genesis
in 1995, with the Super Nintendo
version being co-developed by Blizzard.
Brevik pitched the idea
for Diablo as a turn-based RPG
to different publishers, but was
turned down.
Diablo, ja, das habe ich schon mal gelesen.
Coming off the success of Warcraft,
picked up the game and requested
that it be changed from turn-based to real-time.
Das ist doch erst mal rundenbasiert gewesen.
Alter, sah das erste Warcraft-Scheiße aus.
And once he got the green light for the game,
Condor Games became Blizzard North,
and Diablo was released in 1996.
Diablo was released in 1996.
It was a smash hit on the PC,
with over 2.5 million games sold.
Diablo was underpowered.
The Wizard war eindeutig die beste Klasse in Diablo 1.
The Wizard was eindeutig die beste Klasse in Diablo 1.
Diablo 1 hat es geschafft,
komplett random generierte Umgebung zu haben,
was Diablo 3 bei Release nicht geschafft hat.
Diablo 3 war bei Release fast komplett statisch.
Weiß nicht, wie man das so verkacken konnte.
Loot for your character over and over again.
It's fair to say that Diablo changed the face of computer gaming forever.
It spawned two more sequels,
and Blizzard are continuing to develop updates to the game,
even to this day.
Do you guys not have phones?
Yeah, you guys all have phones.
But the original Diablo was a PC-exclusive game,
which had console owners drooling.
The game was totally controllable with a mouse.
Click where you want to move to
and your character will move there.
Click an NPC to talk to them
and click on the monsters to attack.
This user experience hasn't changed
and is a staple of Diablo-style games.
It's what makes the game so addictive.
The mouse buttons would also allow you
to heal and cast spells too.
It was simple and brilliant.
In 1998, Climax Studios,
who had worked on porting some of Blizzard's
PC games to consoles previously,
released Diablo.
Ach so, auf YouTube.
lernt. Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Das Einzige, was es dir bringen würde, ist Abi,
beziehungsweise Fachabi, falls du studieren willst.
Aber die Ausbildung an sich ist komplett
für den Arsch.
Also sie bringt dir gar nichts, es interessiert keinen Menschen, dass du die gemacht hast.
Außerdem kannst du auch
heutzutage, zumindest in Hessen,
gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass du sogar
mit Realschulabschluss studieren kannst, wenn du später studieren willst.
Vor allem, wenn du Berufserfahrung hast.
Also Abi ist gar nicht
mehr unbedingt notwendig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es in anderen Bundesländern ist.
In Hessen ist es so.
Es gibt sogar in Hessen mittlerweile
ein Testprogramm.
Habe ich gelesen bei der Uni Frankfurt.
Ein Testprogramm, da musst du noch nicht mal was gelernt haben.
Du kannst direkt mit einem Realschulabschluss
sagen, hier, ich will studieren.
Das Einzige, was du dann machen musst, ist
quasi
belegen, dass du hingehst
und
dass du die Prüfung schaffst
zwischendurch. Was ja irgendwie auch
logisch ist.
Nein.
So einfach sinnlos Leute
da hinsetzen will man wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Also es gibt in Hessen
ein Programm, da kannst du direkt,
also da kannst du ohne irgendwelche
Voraussetzungen mit Realschulabschluss
studieren. Wie gesagt,
du musst bloß belegen, dass du hingehst und
dass du die Prüfung packst.
Also die wollen halt nicht irgendwelche Leute
da hinsetzen, die einfach nur
Däumchen drehen.
Wenn ein Spiel für eine Konsole eröffnet wird,
ist es ein großer Deal. Diablo ist ein
PC-Game. Und wenn der PlayStation 1
Port veröffentlicht wurde, waren die Fans
der Spiele begeistert.
Auf der PS1 gibt es keine Maus.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es einen PlayStation 1
Port von Diablo überhaupt gibt.
... hat sein Kontrollschema verändert, um
direkte Bewegung mit dem Analog-Stick zu unterstützen.
Und Hotkeys von verschiedenen Aktionen
wurden an die Knöpfe eingestellt.
Es ist ein solider Port, aber
im Vergleich zu den krispen SVGA-Visuals
der PC-Version, gibt es etwas,
was nicht da ist. Hauptsächlich wegen der
Limitationen des PlayStation-Hardware
selbst. Climax hat overall einen guten Job gemacht,
mit dem, was sie hatten. Es gibt sogar zwei
Play-Local-Co-Op-Bildungen, die
eine Willkommens-Edition sind.
Zurück auf den PC. Diablos
Anforderungen an die Zeit waren Windows
95 mit einer Maus, Keyboard und einem
CD-ROM-Drive und zumindest ein Pentium-
Prozessor, der 60 MHz läuft.
Es hat auch DirectX 3 für seine
Grafik-API genutzt. Für die längste Zeit
versucht Diablo, auf modernen PCs zu arbeiten,
ist fast unmöglich. Es gab einige
Party-Patches und Hacks, die man nutzen
konnte, mit einigen unterschiedlichen
Ebenen von Erfolg. Aber für Jahre war es
schwierig, das Spiel zu laufen, ohne dass man
Zugang zu einem alten Windows-95-Computer
hatte. Die meisten Leute haben sich einfach
nicht geäußert und das Spiel wurde nur
verabschiedet in Bezug auf die Sequenzen.
Es war nicht bis kurz vor, als GOG
Diablo 1 und 2 von modernen Maschinen
vor diesem Jahr veröffentlicht wurde.
Die GOG-Version patcht Routinen in den
exekutierbaren Grafik- und Sound-APIs, um
Sie den Spiel auf Ihrem modernen PC zu
spielen und Sie zu hacken und zu slashen,
wie Sie es wollen. Aber es ist immer noch
nur Windows...
Ich würde immer Diablo 2 vorziehen, Diablo 1.
Diablo 2 war mit Abstand das beste Game in
der Serie.
Wir sind von Windows 95 nach Windows 10 gegangen.
Aber was, wenn man Diablo auf einem Mac,
Linux oder sogar einer Spiel-Konsole spielen will,
wie zum Beispiel der Nintendo Switch?
Da Blizzard das Spiel nicht mehr hat, gibt es
keinen einfachen Weg, es auf
etwas anderes zu laufen als ein Windows-PC.
Nun, ich will klar sein, dass ich nicht...
Ich habe das hier so gelabert, als wäre
es ein Reinhard.
Der hieß so...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den auch gibt.
...suggestioniert, dass Blizzard den
Gehör-Code für Diablo 1 verloren hat.
Das Spiel ist nicht nur für ihre Interessen
relevant, sondern es ist seit 2001, seit
dem letzten Patch, und wie erwähnt,
ein möglicher...
Da muss ich mal überlegen, jetzt mal
ernsthaft. 2001 gab es den letzten Patch.
Das Spiel ist 1995 rausgekommen.
Das ist auch schon eine lange Zeit.
Ich meine, das war jetzt damals nicht so
unnormal, dass man Spiele eine Weile
hat, aber Blizzard ist bekannt
dafür gewesen, Spiele wirklich extrem lang zu supporten.
Man darf nicht vergessen, für Diablo 2,
das kam glaube ich 98 oder so raus,
oder 99,
auf jeden Fall ein bisschen her
schon, gab es sogar letztens
erst noch einen Patch.
Wie geht's? Assembler,
geh fort!
In Japan, Sony
had a long reputation of not double-checking
things left on retail copies of games.
Back in 2013,
the entire source code for Beatmania
5th Mix was discovered
on a Beatmania Best Hits
PlayStation 1 game.
And when Climax Studios
was given the job of porting Diablo
to the PlayStation 1, naturally
Blizzard had sent them the source code
as their starting point.
But somehow inexplicably
on the Japanese version of Diablo 1
contained a file on the disc
with the extension .sym.
Now, if you're not...
5.8 oder so,
sondern man würde gerne lesen,
Fehler in Funktion male Grafik.
Dafür braucht man so einen
Debug-File, so ein
Symbol-File, dass man eben weiß,
wie der Kram heißt.
Kommentar ist zu lang, wie verlink ich den?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich kann den Comment gleich raussuchen.
Sag mal nur nochmal, unter welchem Video das gewesen ist.
War das unter dem, dem,
dem, dem, das war nicht im Battlefield-Video,
das war davor.
Das war das dem, so gut oder schlecht,
oder gut versus schlecht ist Modern Warfare oder so.
Können wir uns gleich angucken.
Zu dem Comment kann ich gleich im Stream was sagen.
Okay.
Deswegen gibt's ein Release-Bild.
Deswegen kannst du normalerweise
im Debug-Mode oder im Release-Mode
kompilieren. Und wenn du im Release-Mode
kompilierst, dann hast du keine Debug-Symbols drin.
Alternativ gibt's unter Linux
das Kommando Strip.
Das hat nix irgendwie mit sonst was zu tun.
Sondern damit kann man
Debug-Symbols aus dem
aus dem Binary
entfernen.
Aber hatten sie wahrscheinlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, das kommt noch dazu,
Beatport. Eigentlich ist die Release-Version,
die du kompilierst ohne Debug-Symbole,
auch schneller.
Und das ist ein proprietärer Blizzard-Archive-Fileformat,
ohne läuft das Spiel ja nicht.
... in almost all Blizzard-Games
since Diablo.
Inside the MPQ there's one particular file
that contains a debug version of Diablo.exe,
which again, if you disassemble it,
contains crucial information about the game,
with things known as
assertion statements.
These statements are checks to determine
if a piece of code or whatever it is
holds true.
For example, if I write a simple line of code like this,
the assertion statements...
... and huge blocks of code...
... must hold true, otherwise the programming...
Oh, übrigens, Leute, Moment, ich muss mal kurz unterbrechen.
Ich hatte eine richtig geile Idee
für ein Stream und ein Video.
Zeig euch mal was.
Ich wollte mir
irgendeine kleine Programmieraufgabe
ausdenken
und dann wollte ich auf
Fiverr
dann wollte ich auf Fiverr
Programmierer suchen, die das für mich programmieren.
Mit Source-Code.
Und dann gucken wir uns an,
im Stream oder im Video,
was die Leute auf Fiverr programmiert haben.
Hire Overwatch-Coach.
Du lässt ernsthaft Sachen
auf Fiverr programmieren? Ja, was denn so zum Beispiel?
LP
Playfair
für was?
Ach, hier oben. Hey Max, ich fahre morgen meine Ausbildung
als Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration
an. Hältst du Tipps
oder Sachen, die du damals anders gemacht hättest?
Eigentlich nicht.
Kommt immer ein bisschen auf den Laden
an.
Eigentlich nicht.
Das Einzige, was du dir merken solltest, ist,
je nachdem, in welchem Laden du landest,
du machst die Ausbildung nicht, weil du schon alles kannst,
sondern weil du es lernen musst.
Oder weil du es lernen willst.
Wir haben einige Azubis schon gehabt,
die auch der Meinung waren, so nach dem Motto, sie wissen alles,
was in der Regel nicht stimmt.
Es ist vollkommen okay,
wenn du in deiner Ausbildung von was keine Ahnung hast.
Es sollte
natürlich immer weniger werden mit der Zeit.
Okay. Ja, das könnte man echt machen.
Wir brauchen bloß,
wir brauchen nur irgendwas,
was man
braucht.
So, Programming,
Desktop-Application.
Gucken wir mal.
Da müssen wir uns irgendeine kleine Aufgabe ausdenken.
Was sind das für
Preise? Gucken wir mal.
Kann ich jetzt keine Raute machen?
I will do
Programming.
Drag-Stream.
Huge. Stufe 1.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Samus Climber.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal kurz hier,
was das so kostet.
Starting at 4,77.
Und dann gucken wir das Video fertig und dann beantworte ich
das Comment von, oh, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Von Drag-Stream
zu seiner Ausbildung.
Also hier zum Beispiel.
I will do C-Sharp,
C++, C and Java
Programming. Also,
oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, Java
Programming. So, was
kostet's? Economy
Package 4,77.
Programs,
Language Select will
consist of a single class or multiple
short classes, including
source code. Standard.
Moment, der will jetzt ernsthaft,
bezahlt den nach Klassen?
The fuck, was ist das?
Hä?
Was ist das?
Okay, okay, was
könnte der zum Beispiel für uns
programmieren? Wir brauchen, Leute,
da müssen wir uns echt mal Gedanken machen.
Wir brauchen irgendeine kleine, eine kleine
Aufgabe, einen Twitch-Bot
oder sowas, oder
einen Twitch,
der soll einfach ein
PPGA-Board programmieren, was wir auch schon mal
programmiert haben im Stream. Also quasi
eine ASP.NET Web-Anwendung,
die in
einem Twitch-Channel schaut,
wenn ich
erwähnt werde und es dann darstellt.
Die sollen einfach das
PPGA-Board nochmal neu programmieren.
Das ist total kurz und knackig,
das machst du innerhalb, das machst du mit
...
haben wir ja gesehen im Stream, das machst du ja mit zwei, drei
Code-Files, das ist ja nicht viel, das hat vielleicht
vier, vier, fünfhundert Zeilen Code
oder so, mit, mit dem ganzen
C-Sharp geblubbert drumherum.
Die sollen, das machen wir,
die sollen PPGA-Board, das PPGA-Board
programmieren. Also wer das PPGA-Board
nicht kennt, ich hab's hier irgendwie gerade kaputt gemacht,
ähm, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Das ist
nicht viel, das ist ein
Programm, was
im Prinzip aus
...
ein bisschen HTML besteht.
Funktioniert's
eigentlich mittlerweile?
Geht das PPGA-Board wieder?
Warum nicht? Warum, was
hab ich, was hab ich da kaputt gemacht?
Ja, ich hab's kaputt gemacht,
ich weiß nicht warum. Ich hab, ich hab nichts
dran geändert, aber es startet nicht mehr.
Das, das lassen
wir die programmieren, das ist wirklich gut.
Das ist auch wirklich simpel, das,
ja, BeatPro, das ist simpel, das kann fast jeder.
Deswegen, ähm, ist das ein guter,
ein guter Auftrag für so einen Fiverr,
für so einen Fiverr-Typ.
So, also gucken wir mal an. Bei dem,
bei dem würde das 4,77 Euro
kosten. Will Consist of a
... Wir, wir, wir buchen Standard, wir buchen
Standard. Wir buchen Standard,
weil du kannst das ohne Probleme
in, äh, in 5,
in, in 5 Classes
ohne Probleme machen.
Ja, ich zeige euch mal, wie das PPGA-Board
Source Code mäßig bei mir aussieht.
Leider kann ich's nicht starten, weil ich's irgendwie
zerstört hab. Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich
gemacht hab, aber irgendwie hab ich's kaputt gemacht.
Leider was unable to detect MSBuild.
Kann es sein, dass ich meine
Leider-Settings irgendwie
g-g-g-geschrottet habe?
Not found. Warum?
Ah.
Ah ja.
Save. Vielleicht geht's jetzt.
Load failed. Reload.
Geht es jetzt?
Ah!
Ich hätte das vielleicht nicht updaten sollen.
Also ich zeige euch mal, was wir machen, was, was
wir die beauftragen können zu programmieren.
Das ist total, total simpel.
Das ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger fast schon alles.
Ähm.
Bisschen HTML und ein bisschen C-Sharp.
Sollen wir mal starten das Ganze? In der Hoffnung, das läuft jetzt.
Okay.
5000. Also, machen wir mal auf.
PPGA-Board.
Da ist es.
Genau. Das Programm macht
nichts anderes, wie sich
in den Twitch-Chat einzuloggen
und alle Fragen, die
Ad-Channel-Besitzer sind,
mitzuschneiden. Das ist alles.
Mehr macht das nicht.
Und man hat einen Knopf, man hat einen Knopf zum löschen.
Der eigentlich hier oben
alles löschen sollte, aber es nicht macht.
Das war's.
Also das ist wirklich nicht, nicht großartig kompliziert.
Sowas sollen die programmieren.
Guck, der schneidet mit,
was der Chat gerade, was der Chat
bastelt. So. Was man dazu braucht,
ich sage eben, ich hätte das gerne als ASP.NET
Core-Anwendung.
Was man dazu braucht ist, gut,
Startup zählt nicht. Startup ist default im Template.
Was man dazu braucht, ist eigentlich nur
eine HTML-Seite.
Die 118 Zeilen lang ist.
Inklusive CSS
und JavaScript.
Und was man dazu braucht,
ist eine Klasse, die sich in Twitch-Chat einloggt.
Äh.
Und einen
Mini-Controller, der das Ganze ausliefert.
Also das sind, wie gesagt, noch nicht,
ich habe gesagt, 400 Codezeilen,
das ist noch weniger. Das sind, das sind
40, das,
das sind 40, das sind 20,
60,
100, 160,
160 Zeilen C-Sharp
braucht man inklusive Boilerplate
und allem und
120 Zeilen HTML.
Also das ist nichts im Endeffekt.
Das machst du in, das machst du in, in,
in zwei Stunden, wenn du keine Ahnung
von hast. So. Und, ähm,
das, das
geben wir mal so, das geben wir mal denen hier
als Auftrag. Das, das, das probiere
ich echt mal aus.
Die kriegen das als Auftrag und, ähm,
dann schauen wir mal, was für
Software rauskommt. Ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant.
Ich meine, der Typ hat ja auch hier C-Sharp,
hat er auch HTML?
Wir können ihn trotzdem
beauftragen. Dann gucken wir mal, was rauskommt.
Web Programming.
I will create ASP.net
MVC Web Application.
238!
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Gibt es bei euch noch einen Azubi zum Vergleich?
Mir fällt gerade kein Anwendungs- äh, Anwendungs-
Entwicklungs-Azubi ein bei uns, der das machen könnte.
Wieso
willst du unbedingt was beauftragen, was du schon kannst?
Na, das, was man mit dem vergleichen kann, was ich selbst gebastelt
hab. Warum soll er es denn
in ASP.net machen? Naja, weil das
ein Web Framework ist, von dem ich Ahnung hab.
Ich kann, ich kann schlecht, äh,
Java Swing, äh, äh,
beurteilen, was er da programmiert hat.
Zumindest nicht so
im Detail.
I will do Android and iOS
Application ASP
Web App Development.
Okay.
I will do Web
Apps with ASP.net
and SQL. Ja, dann zeig mal her.
Was kostet's?
Basic Development and Bug Fixing.
I will create responsive
Application from scratch.
Okay, das gucken wir uns dann mal an.
Also, wir schauen uns jetzt erst mal das Video fertig an
zu Diablo und dann, ähm,
gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns das Comment
von, äh, unter dem YouTube
Video an. Vom,
wo ich wieder den Namen
vergessen hab, vom Trackstream.
...error out.
It deliberately stops the code from continuing,
so the programmer knows there is a bug in
the code that needs to be fixed.
When a debug version of an executable
is built, the assertion statements
are built into the code. When a release version
of the code is built, they are stripped
out. If we look at the hidden Diablo
debug executable in the mpq
file, it contains lots of assertion
statements... Oder haben wir jemanden, der sich auch hier im
Stream dran versuchen möchte?
Dann können wir das nämlich mit jemanden hier
aus dem Stream vergleichen und was
die Leute bei Fiverr abliefern.
Der Eax, der Eax möchte es mal, ja.
Am PPGA Board.
Nur in Node.
Können wir machen, Node krieg ich auch, kann ich mir auch angucken
und lesen. Und halbwegs
einschätzen.
Wenn das Frontend mit Angular
auch okay ist, du kannst das Frontend
kannst du machen mit was du willst.
Nur das Backend hätte
ich gerne in, in, in ASP.NET
Core.
Frontend kann man machen, in was man will.
Ein Frontend ist ja in Ordnet wirklich
gerade die Ausgeburt der
Schönheit hier irgendwo, ja.
Frontend in Excel. Wenn ihr das
in Excel machen wollt, wäre ich sogar auch dabei,
ja.
Was machen? Hab's nicht mitgenommen.
Also, die Idee war,
dass ich auf, also die Idee war,
dass ich das PPGA Board, was ich mal
programmiert hab, also hier diese
250 Codezeilen, der quasi
dieser Twitch Chatlogger
ähm
den wollte ich nochmal
beauftragen, auf Fiverr programmieren zu lassen.
Und dann mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Da hab ich bei der Gelegenheit gesagt,
wir können es ja mal so machen, vielleicht möchte jemand
im Stream sich auch daran versuchen
und das zu programmieren. Wie gesagt,
da brauchst du wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden
oder so für, dann hast du was ganz Gutes zusammen.
Ähm, und dann vergleichen wir mal,
was die Leute hier im Stream fabrizieren
zum Vergleich, was irgendwie ein
ein 9,53 Euro
Programmierer von Fiverr oder ein
9,77 Euro Programmierer von Fiverr
verzapft. Hat man das nicht so in
30 Minuten? Joa.
Also ich würd mal so zwei Stunden ansetzen.
Challenge accepted.
Also was man machen soll,
also was man machen muss, ist
im Prinzip ganz einfach. Also ich zeig,
ich zeig euch gar nicht, was man machen muss, sondern
nur was am Ende rauskommen soll.
Ich möchte ein Webinterface haben,
was Chatnachrichten
mir anzeigt,
die an mich gestellt wurden.
Live, ja.
Also gerade, gerade laufend im
im Stream.
Also wenn jetzt hier irgendjemand ein AdWoblo ausschreibt, will ich,
dass das Ding das mitloggt, so dass ich keine
Fragen mehr übersehen kann. Das ist das, was rauskommen soll.
Das muss im Frontend nicht so aussehen,
das ist die Funktionalität, die ich,
die ich haben will.
Und ich hätte gerne das Backend
in, äh, ASP.NET Core
und das Frontend ist mir
vollkommen egal.
Ich mein, das Frontend sollte im Browser laufen,
aber, ähm,
mit welchem Framework ihr das macht, ob ihr
das mit, äh,
from scratch, irgendwelche jQuery-Geschichten
oder direkt JavaScript im Browser, ist mir
egal. Ja.
Und am besten dann das Ganze
auf GitHub,
dass wir es uns angucken können.
Und nachher beauftrage ich auf Fiverr ein paar Leute,
das, auch sowas zu programmieren.
I will create your website in ASP.NET
MVC für
477!
Das glaube ich nicht. Für 477 würde ich
als Programmierer nicht mal aufstehen und mich einloggen.
Was soll programmiert werden? Wir machen das anders.
Ich schreib mal nen Text zusammen,
den ich auch den
Fiverr-Jungs, ähm,
schicke.
Und den gleichen Text
lade ich auf Pastebin hoch und, ähm,
wobei
wir können das gleich schreiben. Wir gucken jetzt erst mal
das Video fertig, dann beantworte ich die Frage von
Trackstream in, im, unter YouTube
und dann, dann, dann schreiben wir nen Text zusammen
für die Fiverr-Leute, was programmiert werden soll.
...
It looks great in both handheld and dock modes.
This port didn't take very long.
Moment, der hat die App jetzt auf der Switch zum Laufen gekriegt?
Hab ich gar nicht richtig aufgepasst.
No longer are we constrained to using Windows.
This code would run on just about anything out there.
The biggest things that I needed to do was implement the Playstation 1 style movement.
Maxi 7 Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Remember, PC Diablo uses a mouse, so that does not translate well to the Switch at all.
Of course, I could have implemented touch, and that may be something for later.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, der hat quasi den Playstation Diablo Source Code irgendwie umgewurstelt, dass er auf der Switch läuft.
And as a bonus to everyone and those who use a modified Switch, my port is available with full source code and binaries.
It's open source homebrew after all.
Check it out on my GitHub page.
Link is in the description below.
So if you have a modded Switch, download it, drop in your MPQ file from Diablo 1.
And enjoy some old school 1996 hack and slash Diablo action on your Nintendo Switch.
Das ist gut.
So in conclusion, while source code makes life much easier for modern ports and remakes, it's not necessarily needed.
Reverse engineering techniques and thorough investigation of all assets and code from the original game may all that be required.
Galaxy hacks reverse Diablo and was just one person.
With a much larger team.
Working on reverse engineering of the game like dot em you working on Final Fantasy 8.
You don't need the source code.
There is everything in the binary files.
And with a stroke of luck or two, you can recreate the game and enjoy it once again on your modern game systems.
So there you have it guys, that's the story of Diablo from Blizzard in 1996 that was completely
reverse engineered in 2018 by Galaxy hacks and the source code was completely reconstructed
from absolutely nothing.
Other than the snippets of debug information that were found on the discs themselves on the original release disc on the Japanese PlayStation 1 version as well as the PC version of the game.
And you know, it's something that I really wanted to illustrate to you guys that reverse engineering of games is achievable and is possible, you know, to get games.
Das Schöne an den alten Games ist ja auch, dass sie noch irgendwie halbwegs übersichtlich sind.
Reverse engineer mal sowas wie Crysis.
Das ist vorbei.
Ich hab' ja gar nicht richtig gesucht.
Ich bin ja eigentlich ganz zufrieden da wo ich jetzt grad bin.
Aber ich gucke jetzt in letzter Zeit.
Weil ich kann jetzt was meines suchen.
Das ging ja die letzte Woche.
jahre über gar nicht jetzt bin ich einfach mal ein bisschen gucken was es
gibt ich will aber nicht unbedingt wechseln
welchen api endpoint hast du verwendet um alle messages im chat zu bekommen das
ist ja die auch wenn ich das jetzt zeige wie es gemacht habe ist ja langweilig
max warum bekomme ich wenn ich hier im chat bin immer irgendwelche scam pms
deswegen habe ich pms ausgeschaltet oh das war's für unsere low level für
unsere low level fans hier das ist so eine richtig typische c++ klasse einfach
mal eine klasse 653 zeilen lang und das ist noch eine kurze c++ klasse wenn
immer manche cute cute klassen anguckt dann sind irgendwie 8000 zeilen lang oder
so warum hättest du den job nicht wechseln können können hätte ich schon
aber ich habe ich habe mich dafür entschieden die das programm was die zur
betrieblichen altersvorsorge anbieten abzuschließen und es gibt so eine
komische regelung dass wenn du das abschließt da bezahlst du ja unter
arbeitgeber teile ein und die
teile der arbeitgeber an einbezahlt hat können verfallen wenn du nicht so und so
lange dabei bleibst so als gucken wir uns mal das haben zur fachinformatiker
ausbildung an von von nixer etwas mit nixer was im namen kann ich jetzt
nämlich was zu sagen wirst du die modern warfare kampagne
spielen ja klar ja da ist also um dieses comment geht's kann mir auch daran
erinnern wollte ich nämlich wollte ich nämlich ich schon was zu sagen habe ich
auch hier fragen gekündigt wollte ich ein video zu machen also er schreibt
kann es doch vielleicht noch mal was zur ausbildung zum studium in der
informatik macht ich hab ja nicht studiert da muss ich mal zu sagen
ich kenne jeder mitleid ich habe mein leute ich stirne aber ich hab's noch
nicht studiert aktuell sieht die lage bei mir so aus
dass ich auf einer informationstechnischen berufskolleg einer
schulausbildung mit abitur machen und alles anzweifle denn sowohl technische
informatik als auch programmiertechnik elektrotechnik aber auch englisch liegt
mir einfach anders als beispielsweise zwei beispielsweise franzosensische
dass die französisch nicht liegt kann ich kann ich verstehen morgen geht das ganze spaß in die
zweite runde so genannte q1 und ich habe seit sechs wochen bauchschmerzen kenne ich auch hatte
ich früher auch ich habe ja auch ein paar sachen gemacht wo ich keinen bock drauf hatte das ist
sagt das sagt richtig ja wenn du sommerferien hast und dann quasi schon ab der hälfte der
sommerferien denkst auf demnächst muss ich wieder hin das ist scheiße das hat auch auf
das hat auch keine jetzt keine zukunft ist wie und ich habe seit sechs wochen auch schätzen wenn
ich an morgen denke deshalb ist mir eigentlich klar dass ich was ändern muss da mir informatik
im gegensatz zu mathe und co schon immer spaß gemacht hat und man sagen muss da wird jetzt
der der studierte informatiker sachen dass man das gar nicht gar nicht wirklich trennen kann aber ich
weiß was du meinst du meinst rumbasteln an hardware und als netzwerk geschichten und
software sachen du meinst jetzt nicht die hardcore theorie was was programmieren und
mathe angeht
hat mit vier meinen ersten rechner zusammengebaut und mit fünf mein erstes kleines c programm
geschrieben also als kann ich sagen wenn du gerne programmiert bist du wahrscheinlich in
mathe nicht schlecht was bloß diese komische mathe geschichte aus der schule im kopf natürlich beides
mit hilfe erwachsener denke ich seit fast einem jahr darüber nach ob eine ausbildung nicht doch
besser gewesen wäre mir ist klar dass ich da auch mathe brauche aber garantiert muss ich dann nicht
von kurven diskussion und konsorten verstehen ein brauchst du nicht also während der ausbildung
fachinformatiker brauchst du brauchst du kein mathe man braucht fast schon zu wenig mathe die
fahrt die fachinformatiker ausbildung ist fast mathe frei man hat noch nicht mal in der berufsschule
mathe man hat fast schon zu wenig aber zurück zum punkt zu kommen wäre ganz nice wenn du folgenden
sachen was sagen könntest da finde ich dass die meisten online quellen das nicht wirklich hinreichen
viel hat die ausbildung ausbildungs und fachinformatik mathe zu tun gar nix gar nix
0 noch nicht mal ein programmieren das was man den programmieren in der berufsschule macht ist
der komplette witz ja okay wenn man mal hat im ersten halbjahr ein bisschen elektrotechnik da
musst du multiplizieren und und addieren und und ja das war fast schon mal irgendwie
potenz oder so aber also nicht wirklich ja was lässt sich gehaltstechnisch machen und wirken sie
im bund wie wirken sich qualifikationen auf das gehalt aus pauschal kann man sagen wenn du studiert
hast verdienst du mehr wir sind in deutschland allerdings ist kann man das auch wirklich nur
so pauschal sein und im einzelfall muss das nicht so sein wir haben bei uns beispielsweise leute die
Die haben studiert, die arbeiten im 24-7-Support und wir haben die übelsten Noobs, in Anführungsstrichen, was Ausbildung angeht, die im Security-Team arbeiten.
Also sie sind keine Noobs, sondern die haben quasi nichts in der Richtung gelernt.
Also das hat nicht unbedingt, vor allem nach ein paar Jahren Berufserfahrung, so entscheidend was zu sagen.
Aber man kann natürlich sagen, in der Regel verdienst du mehr Geld, wenn du was studiert hast.
Wie sieht es mit der Stabilität des Arbeitsplatzes aus?
Ich höre öfters mal, dass Informatiker oft ihre Arbeitgeber wechseln.
Das kommt drauf an.
Aber wenn du selbstständiger bist, wenn du irgendwie, wie sagt man so schön, Freelancer bist, was natürlich aber auch nur mit ein bisschen Erfahrung geht und vielleicht auch ein bisschen Kontakten.
Wobei heute, heute nicht.
Heute meldest du dich auf Xing an und trägst ein, keine Ahnung, Evangel Basics.
Ich kenne mich mit Linux aus, kann ein bisschen Python programmieren.
Schon hast du die übelsten Typen am Start, so nach dem Motto, hier, wir wollen dich verschachern an irgendeinem Laden.
Also aktuell suchen sie händeringend überall Leute, zumindest Frankfurt und Umgebung.
Geh mal davon.
Geh mal davon aus, dass es im restlichen Teil von Deutschland nicht ganz so extrem sein wird, aber auch.
So.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Ich habe meine Ausbildung gemacht, ich habe danach bei einem Hosting-Anbieter gearbeitet und jetzt arbeite ich die restliche Zeit dort, wo ich jetzt immer noch bin.
Also ich habe, wenn du so willst, einmal gewechselt.
Wenn man den Übergang Ausbildung mal weglässt.
Meinte mit Qualifikation sowas wie, ach du meinst so Zertifikate.
Das kommt drauf an.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also Zertifikate an sich, es gibt noch genug Läden, die irgendwie da drauf stehen.
Was für eine Art Hosting-Anbieter war das denn?
Genauso wie man sich das vorstellt.
Racks mit Servern drin, wo Zeug drauf gelaufen ist.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an mit Zertifikaten.
Also wenn das Zertifikate sind, die nicht 0815 sind, dann kann das schon was bringen.
Also wenn du jetzt z.B. netzwerktechnisch was machen willst und du hast jetzt was Höheres als CCNA, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
CCNA kannst du vergessen, sogar ich habe einen CCNA, das machst du auf halbe Arschbacke und ich habe es nie verlängert und ich bin nur wirklich jetzt nicht der oberkrasse Netzwerk-Dude.
Aber die eine oder andere Auszertifizierung kann mit Sicherheit was bringen, wenn es ein Laden ist, das da drauf steht.
Es gucken aber immer mehr Betriebe an.
Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Es gibt viele Betriebe drauf, letztendlich was man kann.
Also dieses, ich mache die ganze Zeit Zertifikate, ist auch ein bisschen overrated.
Wie wird man als ausgebildeter Informatiker von Studierten behandelt?
So wie von allen anderen auch.
Ich meine, du magst vielleicht den einen oder anderen haben, der sich geil findet.
Aber wie gesagt, das macht im Endeffekt danach keinen großen Unterschied.
Wie gesagt, wir haben Leute, die haben Informatik studiert.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie Wirtschaftsinformatik oder so.
Wir haben Wirtschaftsinformatik, die haben Informatik studiert.
Die arbeiten bei uns quasi für ein Apel und ein Ei im 24-7 Support.
Und andere, die nicht studiert haben, haben richtig, richtig gut bezahlte, leitende Stellen, ja.
Also das, da würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Bringt ein Cisco-Lehrgang wohl viel?
Wird im dritten Jahr...
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, mal so ein Cisco-Lehrgang gemacht zu haben.
Dass man so ein bisschen weiß, wie man Cisco-Geräte konfiguriert.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Musik zu laut?
Passt, denke ich, oder?
Ähm...
Hab von Bekannten und Verwandten gehört, dass die Akademiker oftmals dazu tendieren, die Nase ganz weit nach oben zu stecken.
Nee.
Also, habe ich jetzt nicht die Erfahrung gemacht.
Es gibt Leute, die sind generell so unabhängig davon, ob sie studiert haben oder nicht.
Es gibt Leute, die finden, dass das nicht so einfach ist.
Es gibt Leute, die finden sich übertrieben geil.
Das sind allerdings meistens die, die nicht wirklich geil sind.
Du hast mal die eine oder andere Ausnahme.
Leute, die sich geil finden und auch wirklich was können.
Aber das ist die Ausnahme.
Und Schleimer.
Schleimer gibt es überall.
Ich würde sogar eher dazu sagen, dass Leute, die studiert haben und wissenschaftlich arbeiten können,
eher dazu tendieren, es mit Autoritäten nicht so ernst zu nehmen.
Und eher bei den Vorgesetzten nicht zu schleimen.
Also, es würde ich...
Aber um den kannst du...then würde ich mir eigentlich wenig Gedanken machen.
Ähm...
Wie sind die Arbeitsbedingungen in den Unternehmen im vergleich zu anderen Branchen?
Na ja, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt noch nicht bei 50 verschiedenen Läden gewesen oder so.
Ähm...
Allerdings kann man sagen die Arbeit hat schon seine Vorteile.
Es muss halt die Arbeit cheaper sein, ne.
Du bist nicht draußen...In der Sonne.
will die Sachen shippen.
Du hast in der Regel, je nachdem, außer du arbeitest
im Support, relativ wenig
mit unterschiedlichen Leuten zu tun.
Relativ wenig mit Endkunden
zu tun, was ich
eindeutig
bevorzuge.
Auf Endkunden habe ich überhaupt keinen Nerv.
Auch auf viele unterschiedliche Leute
habe ich keinen Nerv, aber ich habe schon oft gesagt, ich mag generell
Leute nicht.
Aber deswegen sucht man sich ja auch so eine
Arbeit.
Also ich würde sagen, die Arbeitsbedingungen sind
eigentlich ganz gut.
Man muss immer gucken. Das ist halt
sehr davon abhängig, wo man landet.
Also wenn du
zum Beispiel jetzt bei irgendeinem Spieleentwickler landest
und ausgebeutet wirst, ist das was anderes
wie wenn du beispielsweise
irgendwo bei irgendeiner
Bank landest, wo du für jede Änderung
drei Wochen brauchst und die restliche Zeit Däumchen drehst.
Kommt auf den Betrieb an.
Aber letztendlich
liegt es da auch ein bisschen mit an einem selber.
Ähm, man muss nicht jeden Scheiß
mitmachen.
Also aktuell ist es so, wenn man was kann,
was prinzipiell eh das Wichtigste ist,
man muss was können, man muss sich
nicht einfach nur in Windows einloggen können und da
drei Dinger AD anklicken
oder so. Ja, euch mag ich schon, weil
ihr seid ja
aber auch nicht alle.
Ähm,
ja, wie gesagt,
man muss in der heutigen Zeit
hat man auch ein bisschen die Auswahl, wenn man wirklich irgendwo
landet, wo es extrem beschissen ist,
man muss nicht, man muss nicht jeden Mist
mitmachen. Also zum Beispiel
einer der Gründe, warum ich damals gewechselt bin
von diesem, von diesem Hosting-Anbieter, wo ich
gewesen bin.
Yuki Terror 97, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön.
Zum Namen stelle ich mir irgendwie vor, anstatt
Nice, du passt besser der hier.
Ähm, einer der Gründe,
warum ich damals gewechselt bin von diesem Hosting-Anbieter
äh, zu da, wo ich
jetzt bin, äh, waren tatsächlich so
ein paar Sachen, die sie sich überlegt
haben, die ich ziemlich
beknackt fand, ja. Zum Beispiel
haben sie sich überlegt, sie machen ein,
ein, äh, Ausbildungsprogramm,
was, also ein Fortbildungsprogramm,
was die Firma bezahlt,
da so weit, so gut, sag ich ja nix dagegen,
ja. Allerdings haben sie dann
gesagt, dieses Fortbildungsprogramm darfst du plus
samstags besuchen. Da hab ich schon gesagt,
Moment, Leute, ich soll mich,
ich soll samstags auf die Fortbildung
gehen, quasi
unbezahlt, ohne alles,
dass ich da eine Fortbildung mach, wo ihr dann
im Endeffekt auch was von habt.
Also ich hätte dann quasi, äh,
fünf Tage die Woche gearbeitet
und dann samstags
quasi noch irgendwelche Fortbildungen
gemacht und dazu kam, dass es nicht
einfach irgendwelche Fortbildungen waren, sondern es waren
schwere Dinger, wo man auch lernen musste
dafür. Da war dann sowas wie Cisco, äh,
Dings, wie heißt, Cisco
Internet Engineer, wie heißt,
also wirklich, wirklich Hammer-Artcore-Dinger
dabei, ja. Oder auch irgendwelche Red Hat
Geschichten, ähm, die nicht, die
wirklich nicht ohne waren. Also da musst du, da musst du,
da musst du nicht nur mal kurz hingehen
auf die Fortbildung, sondern du musst da wirklich
lernen für. Und, ähm,
das ist so eine Sache, das machst du auch nicht
in, in, in drei Wochen mal.
Und dann haben sie sich überlegt, ja gut,
ähm, das gibt's nur samstags, die Fortbildung.
Du musst dich verpflichten dazu,
dass du die Ausbildung bestehst,
was knackt, wie willst du dich dazu verpflichten?
Und du musst dich verpflichten, in einem halben Jahr
so und so viel Fortbildung zu machen,
in einem Ausmaß,
in Kombination mit samstags nur
die Fortbildung und unter der Woche nicht lernen können,
ähm, dass es komplett hirnrissig war.
Und da haben wir damals gefragt,
ja, wie ist das denn, ähm, Samstag,
ich will ja noch was anderes machen. Und da haben sie sich
dazu dann durchgerungen zu sagen, hey,
ihr könnt die Aus-, ihr könnt natürlich die Fortbildung
auch während der Arbeitszeit machen, allerdings
bekommt ihr dann die Arbeitszeit nicht
gut geschrieben. So nach dem
Motto, ich mach dann Minus auf meinem
Arbeitszeitkonto und müsste nacharbeiten, weil
ich eine Ausbildung für die Firma gemacht hab.
Und das war der Punkt, wo ich mir gesagt hab,
leckt mich am Arsch.
Leckt mich komplett am Arsch, ihr könnt mich
mal, ich geh woanders hin.
Deswegen mein ich, man muss nicht, man muss nicht
jeden, jeden Mist mitmachen, vor allem in der heutigen
Zeit. Äh,
Käpt'n Sieg halt zwei Monate, Hitschplein, danke schön, nice.
Ich mein, ich arbeite doch nicht kostenlos.
Hast du dann flott eine neue Stelle gefunden? Ich hatte direkt,
ich hatte direkt das, wo
ich jetzt bin.
Am nächsten Tag.
Ist aber auch glücklich gelaufen,
ja. Also ich
hatte keine Downtime.
Dort Ende des Monats aufgehört
und Anfang des Monats bei, beim
jetzigen angefangen.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, ähm,
aber als du gekündigt
hast, wusstest du das nicht. Doch, doch, doch.
Ähm, das wusste ich
zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Weil, das ist, das ist bei mir relativ glücklich
gelaufen. Wie gesagt, das war ein Hosting-Anbieter
und der Hosting-Anbieter hat unter anderem
Teile des Hostings gemacht
für den, für den Laden, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Wo arbeitest du denn das
verrate ich nicht.
Finanzsektor in Frankfurt, bei einer Bank.
Ähm,
der Hosting-Anbieter hat teilweise das Hosting gemacht
für den Anbieter, also
für die Firma, wo ich jetzt bin.
Das heißt, ich kannte die Leute da schon.
Deswegen, deswegen ging das
relativ, relativ gut.
Das einzige Problem war, dass in meinem Vertrag
sowas drinne stand, wie
man darf der Firma keine Konkurrenz machen oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und da haben sie danach ein bisschen, ein bisschen rumgeätzt
so nach dem Motto, das wird ja überhaupt nicht gehen.
Äh, und das fand ich richtig geil.
Da hat der, der neue
Arbeitgeber dann einfach gesagt,
ja, verklagt uns doch.
Gedreckt!
Und natürlich hat sie keiner verklagt, ja.
Es gibt doch einen Abonnenten, der weiß,
oder es gibt sogar zwei.
Ja, aber das ist schon 10 Jahre her
und da nicht ganz, oder, ist auf jeden Fall schon eine Weile her.
Ähm,
okay, also, weiter, weiter im Text.
Wie sind die Arbeitsbedingungen
in den Unternehmen im Vergleich?
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Was würdest du empfehlen?
Ich bin zwar erst 18,
aber trotzdem denke ich, dass es kein Zustand ist,
dass ich an fast jedem Tag
mit Bauchschmerzen, nein, das ist, das ist kein Zustand.
Das ist auch wirklich belastend, ja.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
Alter, stell dich nicht so an, aber das ist wirklich belastend,
das kann ich nachvollziehen, das ist, das ist kein Zustand, ja.
Das sorgt eher dafür,
dass du irgendwelche Komplexe kriegst im Kopf,
wenn du jeden Tag mit Bauchschmerzen,
Bauchschmerzen aufstehst und hingehen musst.
Ähm, und mich in die Schule zwingen,
weil ich keinen Bock mehr auf einen Großteil der Fächer habe.
Fast jeden Tag,
meistens an zwei Tagen gebündelt,
programmierte ich Elektrotechnik.
Na gut, auch Programmieren ist ja nice.
Programmieren scheint ja doch auch zu liegen,
wenn du schon mit vier dein erstes C-Programm
programmiert hast.
Wie wichtig sind eigentlich
Hochschulnoten, wenn man sich
nach dem Studium irgendwo als Anwälter
anwenden kann?
Schulnoten juckt kein Mensch.
Auf der anderen Seite sind meine Eltern,
meine Mutter im Besonderen nicht so begeistert,
war meine auch nicht,
von der Idee, die Schule abzubrechen
und eine Ausbildung anzufangen,
da sie denkt, dass studierte Informatiker
bessere Bezahlung zu besseren Arbeitslern,
zu besseren Arbeitslern, das stimmt.
So, also man, im Durchschnitt mag das so sein,
aber im Einzelfall,
ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher,
ob das im Durchschnitt überhaupt so ist.
Ähm, ja, es ist bestimmt statistisch so,
dass du in Deutschland, wenn du studiert hast,
immer mehr Geld verdienst als einer,
also statistisch gesehen im Durchschnitt,
immer mehr Geld verdienst als einer, der nicht studiert hat,
aber vor allem in dem Umfeld kommst,
und das finde ich gut,
hauptsächlich darauf an, was du kannst.
Also wenn du dich in Bereichen auskennst,
die gefragt sind,
Bereiche, die vielleicht auch nicht so viele Leute können,
dann ist das scheißegal,
ob du studiert hast oder nicht.
Zum Beispiel aktuell, was voll angesagt ist,
wenn du dich mit irgendwelchen Cloud-Geschichten
und Kubernetes und sowas auskennst.
Das ist zur Zeit voll der Hype,
da stehen sie alle drauf,
und unabhängig davon, ob sie es brauchen oder nicht,
aber viele Firmen denken, dass sie das brauchen.
Das heißt, wenn du dich damit auskennst,
und du musst dich damit auch nicht übertrieben gut auskennen,
das reicht schon, wenn du dich ein bisschen auskennst,
weil damit kennst du dich besser aus,
als die meisten anderen da,
und da gehen die ab,
die wollen dich unbedingt haben.
Egal, scheiß drauf, ob du studiert hast oder nicht.
Und sie sagt, dass ich das erstmal durchziehen soll.
Danke erstmal für das Lesen.
Also, ich denke,
du solltest dich mal danach umgucken.
Also diese Ausbildung hier an der Schule,
das ist,
wie nennt sich das,
richtig geprüfter informationstechnischer Assistent oder sowas glaub ich, ne?
Das ist der übelste Bullshit.
Das braucht kein Mensch.
Das will kein Mensch haben,
und das interessiert auch keinen, wenn er dich einstellt,
dass du das, dass du das hast.
Ähm,
ich, ich weiß, wir haben ein paar Leute im, im Chat,
die auch, äh,
dafür zuständig sind zu gucken, so nach neuen Leuten und sowas.
Könnt ihr mal in den Chat schreiben,
äh, ob euch das in irgendeiner...
So, äh,
ja, ich hab mich gemutet, wo war ich denn stehen geblieben?
Ja, also, ob es euch in irgendeiner Form interessiert.
Also, eigentlich bringt das gar nix.
Das einzige, was es bringen würde, ist, wie gesagt,
dass du vielleicht, äh, danach studieren könntest.
Allerdings, ähm,
ich kann, ich kann das nachvollziehen.
Ich hätte wirklich keinen Bock, mir das jetzt noch zwei Jahre zu geben.
Das dauert ja dreieinhalb Jahre.
Ähm,
und ich denke auch nicht,
dass Studieren wirklich, ähm,
das ist, zumindest zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt für dich,
weil wenn du, wenn du Informatik studierst,
ein bisschen Hang zur Mathe solltest du haben.
Aber eins kann ich dir sagen,
manche, manche Sachen kommen mit der Zeit, ja.
Ich fand in der Schule Mathe übelst beschissen.
Und auch danach.
Mittlerweile guck ich mir auf YouTube Mathe-Vorlesungen an.
Und, äh, guck mir irgendwelche Mathe-Probleme an.
Und, und les dazu Sachen und find das,
zumindest in, in Teilen,
saumäßig interessant, ja.
Manches kommt auch ein bisschen mit der Erfahrung,
ein bisschen mit dem Alter.
Und vor allem, wenn man gerne programmiert.
Also ich sag mal so, alle,
die gerne programmieren,
und ich meine damit jetzt nicht CSS, HTML,
eine Webseite machen,
alle, die, die Spaß daran haben, äh,
was zu programmieren, was ein bisschen Logik erfordert,
sind in der Regel auch nicht ganz scheiße,
was Mathe angeht.
Weil ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
wer hat Programmiersprachen erfunden?
Die ersten Programmiersprachen haben irgendwelche
Hardcore-Mathematiker erfunden.
Also ich würde dir empfehlen, guck einfach mal,
was es für eine Ausbildung gibt.
Es gibt mittlerweile viele Betriebe, die, ähm, Leute suchen.
Und, äh, wenn...
Das bringt ja nichts, wenn du jetzt sagst, ähm,
ich würde jetzt nicht instant die Schule, äh,
abbrechen ohne einen Ausbildungsplatz.
Ich würde aber vielleicht mal gucken, was man so findet.
Und dann, wenn ich was gefunden hätte,
würde ich das sofort machen.
Weil diese schulische Ausbildung, wie gesagt, denke ich, bringt dir nichts.
Also das, was du in dieser Sch...
Den Titel, den du dann bekommst, wenn du diese Ausbildung
geschafft hast, bringt dir nichts.
Und das ist noch nicht mal das Papier, auf dem es steht.
Ähm, das einzige wäre halt,
dass du studieren kannst direkt danach.
Was aber wahrscheinlich, wenn du absolut
kein Mathe-Fan bist,
nicht das für dich ist.
Ich würde einfach nach einem Ausbildungsplatz suchen
und eine Ausbildung anfangen. Außerdem verdienst du dann ordentlich
Kohle. Schon von Anfang an.
Jetzt gibt... Dafür gibt's ja gar nichts.
Ähm, es gab noch eine Frage im Chat.
Wie wichtig sind all... Ne, Moment.
Hatten wir schon. Äh, Hochschulen, Hochschulnoten.
Es ist... Juckt keinen.
Stimmt es, dass es nur auf die Coding-Skills
ankommt? Naja, nicht nur.
Ja? Also natürlich muss man als Programmierer
gut programmieren können. Man braucht allerdings auch
breite Kenntnisse, sag ich mal, in den
Technologien, die eingesetzt werden, weil...
Nur weil ich gut programmieren kann, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass ich mit der... mit... mit...
mit dem Umfeld rumrum klarkomme. Und!
Was auch heutzutage als Programmierer
und auch als...
Was mir auch immer ein bisschen schwer fällt, muss ich sagen.
Als Programmierer, als auch als
ähm...
Egal welche Position,
es ist in der heutigen
Zeit nicht
verkehrt, wenn man
mit Leuten
halbwegs auskommt. So will ich mal so ausdrücken.
Ja? Wie gesagt, ich mag auch keine Leute,
aber
so komplett alleine
in der Kammer sitzen und was
vor sich hin hackt, ist heute halt nicht mehr.
Wobei ich auch deutlich weniger Probleme
hab, mit Leuten auszukommen, die sich technisch auskennen,
als mit Leuten, die sich nicht auskennen.
Was machst du denn bei der Bank? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen
Beruf. Da haben wir ein Kommando für.
Ach, du gehst gerne hin, wenn du in
Programmiertechnik und Co. hast. Ja, das passt doch.
Ich kopiere immer Buchstaben, wenn ich mich konzentrieren
muss, wisst ihr doch. Ist der Typ
hier im Chat oder lädst du das noch hoch?
Ich lad das nicht hoch.
Der ist im Chat. Das ist der.
Trackstream ist das.
Ey, Dönerbruder, pff.
Kommt drauf an.
Ich meine, du musst ja wissen, ob dir,
wo es dir mehr danach ist. Das kann man,
man kann nicht pauschal Raten studieren oder Ausbildung
machen. Das muss, das muss man selber wissen, wo es einem
mehr danach ist. Das kann man,
also, pauschal kann man das schlecht beantworten.
Pluton29.
Pock. Subscriber.
Ich komm mit dem Chat grad nicht hinterher.
Okay, also Trackstream, ich hoffe, dir hat
das geholfen. Was hältst du
von Wirtschaftsinformatik? Du kannst mich
mit jeglichen BWL-Zeugs jagen.
Ja. Ich hab mal überlegt,
mir ein wenig Programmieren beizubringen. Ich weiß leider nur
nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Das ist ganz einfach.
Überleg dir einfach, was du machen willst.
Überleg dir einfach, was du gerne,
was dir auf den Keks geht und was du gerne besser machen
würdest. Ja, also wenn du sagst, hey, ich hätte gerne
irgendwie einen schöneren, pff, keine Ahnung,
schöneren Windows-Taschenrechner, dann
willst du auf jeden Fall Desktop-Anwendungen programmieren.
Oder willst du, vielleicht,
willst du sagen, hey, ich hätte gerne, ich würde gerne
eine Webseite machen. Ja, dann solltest du dir mal überlegen,
ob du nicht vielleicht JavaScript,
CSS, HTML anfängst.
Und dann einfach mal schauen, was es für kostenlose
Bücher gibt. Oder vielleicht auch ein Buch kaufen.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, zum Einstieg und
auch zum Vertiefen sind Bücher, ordentlich
geschriebene Bücher, besser als
Online-Kurse
oder YouTube-Videos. Man kann sich
natürlich Online-Kurse und YouTube-Videos dann angucken, aber
wichtig ist, einfach ein bisschen
programmieren. Weil wenn du selbst
programmierst, lernst du einfach das meiste.
Weil dir auffällt, in dem Moment,
wo es nicht funktioniert, dass du irgendwas brauchst,
wovor du noch keine Ahnung hast.
Ja, Niki, da hast du recht.
Wenn halt Menschen, die Menschen nicht
mögen, untereinander sind, passt alles. Ja, das stimmt so.
Waren wir heute
noch?
Eigentlich wollte ich noch ein paar Videos gucken. Und dann
müssen wir noch Fiverr, müssen wir uns noch einen Fiverr
Text ausdenken,
den ich an die Fiverr-Leute schreiben kann.
EXO2K abonniert
Stufe 1. Ein richtiger,
kein Prime-Sub, aber ein richtiger Sub.
Prime, Subscriber.
Sub, Sub, Subscriber. Nice.
Danke.
A-Break, Switch Prime.
Prime,
Subscriber. Nice, dankeschön.
Nice.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Wirtschafts-
und Wirtschaftsinformatik-Informatiker?
Das eine hat halt BWL-Krempel mit dabei.
Und viel weniger
Informatik.
Du kannst die gerne auf dem Discord veröffentlichen,
wenn du willst.
Aber ich finde zum Einstieg ins Programm,
ist am besten, man hat irgendwas vor Augen,
was man gerne machen möchte.
Was willst du über Fiverr machen lassen?
Ja, da schreiben wir gleich einen Text zu.
Ich will über Fiverr was programmieren lassen,
was wir on-Stream auch schon mal programmiert haben.
Und dann mal schauen,
was die 4,50 Euro-Programmierer
von Fiverr so programmieren.
Gut, so.
Ich hab mit dem Chat wieder aufgeholt.
Das hat jetzt ein bisschen gedauert.
Erstmal alles durchscrollen.
Ja, das haben wir unsere gute Tat für heute schon getan.
Aber schön,
dass du uns so ausführliches Comment geschrieben hast.
Was man daran auch erkennt ist,
dass du nicht einfach nur keinen Bock hast,
den Scheiß zu machen.
Oder dass du nicht einfach nur keinen Bock hast,
irgendwas zu machen.
Sondern, dass du dir wirklich Gedanken machst.
Und deswegen muss ich halt echt sagen,
das ist kein Zustand, wenn du mit Bauchschmerzen
bei uns aufstehst, wenn du da hin musst.
Das ist für'n Arsch.
Und um die anderen Sachen musst du dir, wie gesagt,
eigentlich kaum Gedanken machen.
Was schreib ich den Fiverr-Leuten denn?
Gefällt dir die Skyline
von Frankfurt?
Ja, Skyline von Frankfurt.
So Leute, irgendwie ist mir's grad danach.
Mit Scheiß-Twitter-Qualität.
Ja, da ist die Skyline
von Frankfurt. Sieht doch ganz nett aus
morgens, wenn's dunkel ist, oder?
Oder wenn's halb dunkel ist.
Warum ist die Twitter-Qualität so
scheiße, die ich hochgeladen hab?
Die Qualität müsste viel besser sein,
das 1008 Spiel-Video.
Also ich finde, nachts sieht Frankfurt
wirklich, gut, das ist jetzt morgens grauen,
sieht es wirklich ganz nett aus, wenn man hier über die
Brücke nach Frankfurt reinläuft.
Oder? Findet ihr nicht auch? Hat was.
Ich mein, ich hätte das Handy mal ein bisschen höher
halten müssen, dass man die Hochhäuser besser sieht,
weil die gehen noch ein ganzes Stückchen weiter hoch.
Ich hatte auch ein schönes Bild nach Frankfurt
nachts.
Frankfurt-Kaiserstraße.
Arbeitest du jetzt beim neuen Arbeitgeber noch mit
ehemaligen Kollegen zusammen? Ja, paar sind auch noch
dahin gewechselt.
Kann man auf Twitter
filtern
nur nach, nur nach Videos?
Geht das?
Boah, leck mich, äh.
Kann man nach nur Videos filtern
irgendwie?
Ey, das ist schon ein bisschen her, wo ich das hochgeladen hab.
Ist ja alles auch von diesem Jahr.
Weil das eine Video
Frankfurt bei Nacht war wirklich nice.
Oh, meine dicke Katze.
Spider-Cat.
Hahaha.
Och jo.
Ich scrolle jetzt einfach mal durch und dann suche ich nach
Frankfurt.
Okay, so lange ist das glaube ich noch nicht her.
Alter, wie lange ich schon Zeug auf Twitter gepostet
habe. Oh,
Fressworts.
Ein nices Fressworts gab's da.
Frankfurt City Night, gute
Battlefield-Map. Ich finde, das macht schon ein bisschen was her,
die Frankfurter Skyline.
Ja, Commerzbank.
Also hier.
Ne, nicht Commerzbank.
Äh, war doch Commerzbank?
Kann man zum Beispiel nicht merken.
Hahaha.
Das macht doch was her. Ich finde, das sieht cool aus.
Gibt's
Gibt's einen bestimmten Grund, warum du US-Keyboard-Layout benutzt?
Ich benutze kein US-Keyboard-Layout.
Ich benutze englische Sprache und deutsches Keyboard-Layout.
Next Level.
Okay, was können wir
den Fiverr Leuten
den Fiverr Leuten schreiben?
Aber wie
Also ich hab meinen
Emote-Auftrag, den übrigens
den wir nicht machen werden. Ähm.
Den Emote-Auftrag hab ich viel zu
ausführlich geschrieben.
I'm looking for bla bla bla bla bla.
Okay, also was
Was können wir den Fiverr Leuten
dann schreiben, was programmiert werden soll?
Okay, machen wir es so.
Hi, I'm a Twitch
Streamer.
Ich schick dem
aber nicht meinen Namen, sonst guckt der nämlich nach.
I'm looking
for a web application
with
backend
ähm
Was, was schreiben wir den denn jetzt?
I
I am a Twitch Streamer.
ähm
I
often miss
important chat messages.
ähm
I'm looking for a web application
that
Wie kann man das beschreiben,
was das macht?
Also jetzt geht man mal nicht mit Englisch auf den Keks. Sagt man mal eher,
dass man das verstehen kann, was ich haben will.
ähm
that
that logs
logs and highlights
chat
logs and
highlights chat
messages
send
to me.
To improve my collaboration
with the chat, I'm looking for a tool to monitor
any messages directly to
send to me.
Add username.
Ja.
Okay.
I am a Twitch Streamer.
Okay, ähm.
Ich muss dir bloß noch sagen,
was ich hier
sagen will,
dass ich
äh
Ich muss dir bloß noch sagen, was ich haben will.
Interaction.
Ja, viel besser.
Danke schön.
To monitor
to
log and
highlight
any
message
that mentions my username.
Okay. Ähm
front
and should
front and
and be
in any
but
back and must
be
So.
Okay.
Ich glaube, man checkt jetzt ungefähr,
warum man dem
Da versteht man ungefähr, was ich haben will, oder?
Wow. The fuck?
Alter,
was jetzt?
Fuck, warum twingelst du?
Das ist meine Temperaturanzeige
Weckerding gewesen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der jetzt um 12 einfach mal
anfängt zu klingeln.
Ich weiß es nicht.
So. Wir brauchen jetzt noch
Wir brauchen noch ein Bild vom Frontend,
dass der checkt, was ich, äh
Wobei, wir brauchen kein Bild vom Frontend.
Also, das
Leute, das versteht man doch, oder?
Hi, I am a Twitch Streamer. I often miss important
chat messages. To improve my interaction
with the chat, I am looking for a tool to monitor,
log and highlight any messages
that mention my username.
Frontend
can be written in any Javascript, HTML
Framework
you want.
But
the
Backend must be an
ASP.NET Core App.
So.
Wo fehlt denn a
I am
a
I am a
die
Okay, okay, wir machen noch eins.
Very important, the front end should refresh itself when a new message is registered.
Das ist jetzt Bonus, Bonuspunkte.
Ah ne, das ist endlich die Point, Bonus Points.
Gibt es noch ein paar Bonuspunkte, die wir vielleicht gerne hätten?
Wo er sich ein bisschen austoben kann?
Was könnte man noch so einfaches einbauen?
Ich meine, was kann mein PP-Garbon?
Ach so, äh, Delete Button.
Ja.
Wie viel bezahlst du dafür?
4,77.
Ne, Twitch-E-Modes ist zu viel, das ist zu hart.
Button to delete.
Single or all.
Buttons to delete a specific message.
Page or all messages.
Das ist schon fast Ausbeutung.
Ey, ich hab...
Ausbeutung wär's, wenn er sich nicht dagegen wehren könnte.
Der hat freiwillig das Angebot reingestellt, dass er für 4,77 was programmiert.
Und er sagt für 4,77,
I will develop your complex website in ASP.NET MVC.
Und der, oh, Include Source Code brauchen wir, Include Source Code, wichtig.
Okay, ich würde jetzt noch gerne...
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht mehr sicher, ähm, warum ich das...
Was war mein Gedanke dazu, nicht einfach eine Webseite zu machen?
Weil ich meine, man müsste doch eigentlich auch von einer Webseite Twitch abfragen können.
Warum hab ich ein Backend gemacht?
Weil ich speichern wollte, genau, weil ich eine Datenbank haben wollte, was die Nachrichten speichert.
Browser unabhängig.
Ach ja, wisst ihr was, was wir noch reinschreiben sollen?
Dass die Anmeldung, dass die Anwendung, ähm, funktionieren muss, ohne Twitch-Login.
Must work without logging in, without Twitch-Login.
Wollen wir eben noch reinschreiben, dass wir, dass, dass, dass er die Twitch-IRC-AP verwenden soll?
Nee, das wär zu viel Hilfe, oder?
Das wär zu viel Hilfe.
Das soll er selbst rauskriegen.
Ja, das wär zu viel Hilfe.
So, I am a Twitch-Team, I often miss important chat messages.
To improve my interaction with the chat, I am looking for a tool to monitor, log and highlight any messages that mention my username.
Frontend can be written in any GSHTML-HTML-Framework you want, but the backend must be ASP.NET Core.
Must be, äh, ASP.NET Core application.
Ähm, application must work without Twitch-Login.
Bonus points. Frontend should refresh itself when a new message is registered.
Äh, buttons to delete.
Äh, specific message or all messages.
Also im Prinzip genau das, was ich ja auch eingebaut hab, plus, dass mein Button nicht funktioniert.
So, Leute.
Also, es waren ja vorher ein paar Leute da, die haben gesagt, sie würden sich auch gerne dran probieren.
Wie gesagt, meine, nennen wir es mal, Referenz-Implementierung ist hier.
Die hab ich ja lokal, die funktioniert auch.
Ähm, also man braucht ungefähr 200, so, sagen wir mal 200 Zeilen Code für, ungefähr, inklusive HTML,
JavaScript und, äh, C-Sharp-Code.
Ähm, ach so, was wir noch reinschreiben sollten ist, Chat-Messages should survive, äh, Application-Restart.
Nicht, dass der auf die Idee kommt, das alles in RAM zu schreiben oder so.
Da soll er schon eine SQLite-Datenbank oder so drunter, drunter hauen, ja.
Should survive Application.
So, man versteht's, oder?
Habt ihr noch, hättet ihr noch was?
Also ich meine, das sind keine zusätzlichen Punkte.
Hättet ihr noch irgendwas, wie man es klarer schreiben kann?
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich relativ, relativ klar.
Ähm, das ist relativ klar.
Ich meine, man sieht, ich bin ein Twitch-Streamer, der Nachrichten verpasst.
Deswegen hätte ich gerne ein Tool, was eben den Chat überwacht, äh, wenn, wenn mein Username, äh, erwähnt wird, ja.
Man kann, der darf, Frontend darf er machen, wie er will.
Aber das Backend muss eine ASP.NET Core, äh, Anwendung sein, ja.
Das Ganze muss funktionieren ohne Login auf Twitch.
Tippfehler in Application.
So.
Könntest du das auch selber schreiben?
Hab ich ja schon.
Hier, da.
Läuft ja schon.
Das haben wir schon vor Wochen selber gemacht.
Das sind 200 Zeilen Code oder sowas.
Ich will jetzt wissen, der, der Witz ist ja, ich will wissen, was die Fiverr-Leute daraus machen.
Weil ich meine, für vier, ganz ehrlich, für 4,77 Euro.
Den Code gibt es nirgends wo.
Das wäre ja witzlos, verzeih ich.
Ähm, für 4,77 Euro erwarte ich nichts, ehrlich gesagt.
Basic Development and Bug Fixing.
Standard Create.
Ach so, der will mehr für eine Anwendung, okay.
Programs will consist of a single class of...
Okay, bei dem müssten wir 14 Euro ausgeben.
Bei dem müssten wir, bei dem müssten wir schon 57 Euro ausgeben.
Ich suche mir mal welche raus, die das machen.
Und dann, dann mache ich den Auftrag.
Das ist witzig.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
I will create your website.
Okay, was haben wir, was haben wir denn sonst noch für eine...
I will create your ASP.net MVC.
Den hatten wir gerade schon, ne?
I will develop your complex websites in ASP.net MVC.
Drei Tage Delivery.
One revision, 4,77.
Okay, Leute.
Ordner hinzufügen.
Progress.
Ich hasse, ich hasse diese Lesezeichen von...
Okay, den speichern wir uns.
Progress.
4,77.
Okay, na.
Wie sucht man hier am besten danach?
ASP.net?
I will develop web applications ASP.
Das sind Inder, sind alles Inder, oder?
Vom Namen her.
Say it, Asha.
Na, den Username, den Username kann er konfigurierbar machen.
Ach so, meinst du das Flo?
Ja, nein, mein Username erwähne ich nicht.
Okay.
Reliable, secured, full functional web application.
Exactly according to requirements.
Five pages including source code.
Save.
Progress.
Der ist zu teuer.
Das ist ja ein realistischer Preis.
Das wollen wir natürlich nicht bezahlen, ne?
Den hatten wir schon, oder?
Bei dem kostet er aber 57 Euro.
I will create or modify your ASP.net...
your application.
Sieht mal aus wie zu teuer.
Zu teuer, mehr als 10 Euro bezahlen wir nicht.
I will develop your enterprise web sites with ASP.net Core.
Six pages with responsive design, including source code.
Easy.
Ah, kann man die nach den Bewertungen suchen?
Best selling?
Just.
I will create a website...
website as per your requirements 477 warum sind die alle so billig wie sucht man dann hier
programming hier programming websites web programming ok wir können auch ne foobie on rails anwendung
sp 19 euro zwei tage delivery das ist gut das gefällt mir der passt der passt genau und er
sollte und er sollte auch wissen was er da macht dann auch gute bewertung den nehmen wir den nehmen
wir 20 euro geschenkt wie gesagt für 20 euro machen die meisten leute nicht mehr ihre idee
auf das war übertrieben zu sagen ob der griff
websites wir haben eben den geek hat hat mir eben all will die welle auf asp.net core
mvc web applications für 9 euro perfekt will fix your bucks in this package die welle auf
university project assignment features ach so da macht er nichts neues mehr asp gibt es
eine kann er leider nicht gescheit suchen danach da muss man hier sharepoint support
und
den hatten wir gerade schon pro das ist ja mal ein ernstzunehmender preis das wollen wir natürlich
nicht bezahlen i will die welt auf any type of asp.net application ok also ich würde sagen also
ich überlege mal so 100 euro gebe ich aus dafür das ist mir der spaß wert also 100 euro gebe ich
aus ich werde so machen ich suche mir ein paar leute raus die halt ultra billig sind und dann
ab
eben
0 work
kein
o
477.
I will develop
so complex works as I have asked for
one revision. 477.
Kein Source Code.
Naja, wenn ich das laufen lassen soll
bei mir, muss es ja Source Code geben.
Wie soll ich es sonst laufen lassen?
Führ da nicht irgendein
mir unbekannten Inderkram aus.
Okay, continue.
Kann man vielleicht noch
Source Code auswählen?
Bonus?
Bonus Source Code?
Das schreibe ich ihm dabei,
dass ich Source Code haben will. Da lege ich auch nochmal 5 Euro drauf.
Voll der Gönner
heute, oder? Voll der Gönner.
Gibt es schon mal
9,50 Euro dann für die Anwendung.
Und den probieren wir auch aus.
Oder war das der, wo man Basic nehmen, wo man Standard
nehmen muss?
I will design any
kind of database
ASP.NET Web App.
My expert
der arbeitet
drei Tage für 9,53 Euro?
Okay, also.
Moment, das müssen wir bei dem anderen...
Ha, das haben wir bei dem anderen gar nicht geguckt.
Was hat er noch reingeschrieben?
Dear Customer, I am a senior software engineer
and have more than three years of
programming...
C Sharp macht
View, Bootstrap,
jQuery...
Okay, da steht leider
nichts zu Source Code dabei.
Unlimited Revisions...
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall den Source Code.
Ohne Source Code ist das langweilig.
So viele Leute...
Ich muss erst mal Leute raussuchen,
die potenziell dafür in Frage kommen.
Ich will auf jeden Fall den Source Code.
Ohne Source Code ist langweilig.
Ansonsten müssen wir uns die kompilen oder so.
I will develop Web App, Web API
in ASP.NET Core.
Included Source Code.
Das ist er.
Der Steff019.
.NET Core Anwendung mit Angular.
Design.
Include Source Code.
ASP. Genau das wollen wir haben.
Genau das wollen wir haben.
I will work with...
On the back-end side.
Genau das wollen wir haben.
Genau den wollen wir haben.
Der wird beauftragt.
I will fix your HTML.
Ja, mit 10 Tagen ist auch...
Also für den Preis kann man das ja wirklich nicht erwarten,
dass es schneller geht oder so.
I will do...
ASP.NET MVC-Bilder.
ASP.NET MVC-Bootstrap.
Den hatten wir eben schon.
I will design book covers.
Warum genau ist der in Programming drinne?
I will create the application
with simple pages.
Den hatten wir schon.
Den hatten wir auch schon eben, glaube ich.
Including Source Code.
I will fix bugs
and develop small,
complete static website.
Wo ist...
Hä?
Complete static website.
Allerdings,
hat es drei bis fünf Dynamic Pages.
Was auch immer.
Alles zu teuer.
Die wollen ja noch richtig Geld dafür haben.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir haben genug.
Die werde ich mal alle anhauen
und ihnen das hier schicken.
I am a Twitch-Streamer.
Okay.
Da bin ich echt gespannt, was rauskommt.
Da bin ich echt gespannt.
Könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
Da bin ich wirklich...
Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf.
Macht es Sinn,
die PS4 in der Fritzbox als DMZ einzudrangen?
Nö.
Ich würde immer nur die Ports weiterleiten,
die ich brauche.
Und normalerweise brauchst du es.
Es sei denn, du willst Cod irgendwelche Sachen hosten oder so.
Gar keine Ports weiterleiten.
Welchen Clipboard-Manager du für Linux verwendest?
Irgendwas Selbstgestricktes.
Irgendein Rufi...
Rufi...
Rufi-Plugin, glaube ich.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Clipster.
Clipster-Rufi.
Irgendwie sowas.
Okay.
Okay, ich bin begeistert.
Fiverr.
Was kann man da sonst noch so kaufen auf Fiverr eigentlich,
wenn man was programmiert haben will?
Gucken wir mal Desktop.
Desktop-Applications.
Da weiß ich nicht mal, was das überhaupt ist.
Three Days Delivery.
Cryptocurrency Trading Bot.
Was man nicht alles auf Fiverr kauft.
Linux Programming für 4,77.
Very Simple C++.
Oh, das müsste man auch mal ausprobieren.
Ja.
C++-Anwendung für 4,77.
Was ist Very Simple?
Anstatt Hello World, Hello Fiverr.
Cute-Entwicklung, Herr Korn.
Ja.
Auch 4,77.
Die ganzen Interprogrammer hier.
Lustig.
Ja, also, das machen wir jetzt nicht im Stream,
weil ich will hier keine Kreditkarten und Gedulds eingeben.
Wenn ich das hier order...
Für 4,77 schmeißt niemand seinen Rechner an.
Dann sollen sie nicht 4,77 reinschreiben.
Wenn die da 4,77 stehen haben,
dann soll es...
Es zwingt sie ja keiner, die Sachen für 4,77 da reinzuschreiben.
Ich find's auch unrealistisch.
Ich würd auch für 4,77 kein Fingerkrumm machen.
Aber wenn man sich auf einer Seite anmeldet,
wenn ein Angebot erstellt für 4,77,
dann würde ich auch erwarten, dass man für 4,77 was macht.
Ich mach's trinken.
So.
Okay.
Also, das mach ich jetzt aber.
Das mach ich jetzt aber off-stream,
weil ich will meinen Kreditkarten-Zeug und Paypal-Zeug hier nicht eingeben.
Ja.
Perfekt.
I will help in Java-Programming.
Bloß nicht.
Alter, warum haben wir 250 Zuschauer?
Pock, nice.
Wahrscheinlich kommen viele von YouTube, ha?
Leute.
Kommen viele von YouTube?
Wie sieht's aus?
Oder habt ihr's über Twitch gefunden?
Nach Kobol programmieren.
Oh ja.
Was hat das mit Kobol zu tun?
Heh.
Showing yourself for cool in the seat of Kobold.
Nicht Kobold.
Kobol.
Kobold-Programmer.
Man kann auch gar nicht direkt.
Search instead for Kobol.
Kobol.
Yo, Kobol.
Mainframe-Environment.
Boah, krass.
IBM-Host-Geschichten in Kobol.
Kobol-Programming.
4,77.
relating.
Switch Prime.
Von Twitch Prime auf richtiges Abo gewechselt.
Pock.
Erstmal gucken, dass nicht viele Leute vergessen hab, die gesubbt haben.
browniestop.com
Kobold.
Kann't listen.
Ich frag mich, warum wir da überhaupt noch auf der Arbeit
ein eigenes Team für Datenbacken
und ein eigenes Team für Mainframe haben.
Wenn man sich das doch einfach
für 4,77 bei Fiverr duen lassen kann.
gaszt еlf.
Soll ich mal vorschlagen?
Ich schlag das mal vor, als
huge Einsparpotenzial
einfach alle
DBAs und alle
Mainframe-Leute
entlassen
und Fiverr einkaufen.
Und ich krieg den Bonus,
den man einspart.
Max wird durch Fiverr ersetzt, genau.
Spielst du keinen Warteschlangen-Simulator?
Nee, wenn ich mit WoW Classic angefangen
hätte,
dann
Max würde als erstes entlassen.
Das ist
unbefristet.
So einfach geht das nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt WoW anfangen würde,
dann würde ich
keine Videos mehr machen und keine Streams mehr.
Deswegen hab ich nicht mit WoW angefangen.
Also ich bin begeistert.
Die Fiverr-Geschichte, das wird echt lustig, Leute.
Das
hab ich so im Gefühl.
Und außerdem, wenn ich entlassen werde,
ist kein Ding, dann geh ich einfach auf Fiverr
und melde mich an
für 4,76 Euro
und unterbiete alle.
Wahrscheinlich ist 4,77
das niedrigste, was man anbieten kann, oder?
Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Genug Fiverr.
Ja.
Ähm.
Wollen wir noch was gucken?
Also, eigentlich ist jetzt 12.30 Uhr.
Ich bezahle gleich mal was Futter.
Oder mal anfangen, Mittagessen zu machen.
Fiverr-Auftrag mach ich nachher.
Ach ja, übrigens, Leute, für alle, die
aus YouTube zugeschaltet haben, ist schön, dass ihr
den Weg auch hier auf Twitch gefunden habt.
Nur mal so als Info für alle, die neu sind
hier auf Twitch. Falls ihr
einen Amazon Prime Account habt,
könnt ihr den kostenlos mit eurem Twitch
Account verbinden.
Das Ganze gibt dann Twitch Prime.
Dafür bekommt ihr im Monat
kostenloses Twitch Prime Loot. Und das
Beste ist, ihr könnt
einen Streamer eurer Wahl kostenlos
mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen.
Das könnt ihr einmal im Monat machen.
Kostet euch nix. Normalerweise
würde es 5 Euro kosten. Und ihr
bekommt alle Vorteile, die das mit sich
bringt. Also, sprich, ihr bekommt eine Subpage, ihr bekommt
Emotes. Und wir haben eh die nicesten
Emotes hier im Channel.
Ich hab noch 10 frei. Ich muss noch mehr Emotes.
Aber die Emotes, die wir jetzt haben, sind natürlich Big Brain
Emotes. Und außerdem
äh, sinkt
der Durchschnitts-Ping und der, und es
steigt der Durchschnitts-IQ jedes Zuschauers
mit jedem Sub. Also, das heißt,
wenn ihr Any Primers am Start sind,
dann wisst ihr ja,
was man damit machen kann jetzt.
Genug Sellout.
Schlankschattig
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Das klappt jedes Mal.
Moin.
Ping Sellout kannst du lassen.
Bisschen Cringe. Bisschen Cringe ist nicht schlecht.
Bisschen Cringe ist für mehr Sellout
immer von Vorteil.
Ecochanics. Dankeschön.
Pfeilpferd. Subscriber.
Any Gifters.
Wie war das?
Never subbed?
Never donated?
Free Entertainment?
Ich krieg das grad nicht zusammen. Wartet mal.
Wie ging das?
Ja.
Never subbed? Never donated?
Adblocked? On stone? Laptop? Neighbors?
Wifi? Free Entertainment?
Haha.
So, hab ich irgendwelche...
Jetzt können wir ja mal meinen Chat...
Mein...
Das PPGA-Board angucken.
Ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab an
Chat-Nachrichten.
Ich schätze mal, dass die Angebote
in Dollar und nur in gewissen Abrechnungsstufen
eingestellt werden. Denk ich auch.
Denk ich auch, ja.
Die Emails auf Fiverr gibt's nix.
Gibt's nix.
Alles so unkreativ irgendwie.
Und ich auch.
indische programmierer verdienen 400 bis 400 euro im monat 5 bis 10 euro nebenbei
sind relativ viele kann sein dass man muss ja ein grund haben warum so viele
für sieben für 4,77 euro gibt migrate your exchange environment das würde ich
nicht unbedingt auf fiverr beauftragen ich weiß nicht 47 euro huge cisco leute
das wollten wir mal gucken genau gibt es cisco experten auf fiverr
eine configuration of vpn switch cisco router and mikro tic ja gibt es auch
cisco experten auf fiverr auch für 477
ach der macht für dich packet racer cisco packet racer aufgaben löst er für
dich sehr witzig was da nicht alles gibt fünf euro sind 400 indische rupees
naja
ok das glaube ich nichts mehr dabei wo hast du eigentlich ein mikro tech zeug
gekauft bei amazon bei hatte so ganz hat eigentlich ein super einprägsam da bei
denen hier genau bei denen habe ich viel bestellt weil die über ich habe über
geiz gesucht und die waren relativ günstig
omg
ich glaube hier habe ich viel gekauft aber leute ich kann euch empfehlen geht
über geiz halt geht über geiz halt weil die angebote wenn du über den geiz
halts link in online shops rein gehst dann sind die oftmals billiger als wenn
du direkt über google und sonst was über den job geht omega 0.de tatsächlich die
seite gibt es ja wirklich warum gibt es die seite omega 0.de wegs kuchen 1 wollen
also ich kann nur empfehlen buchhalter access point bringt wirklich was also
zum beispiel diese diese ubiquiti access points auch schon die kleinen die sind
vielfaches besser als das meiste wie man es heute schon im router drin ist
ich habe ja den ich habe den allerdings die haben mittlerweile neue ja
mittlerweile neue ich würde ihn jetzt nicht mal einfach so kaufen
wir haben eine neue serie herausgebracht die auch ziemlich gut sein soll ein
bisschen billiger ist
Ja, aber das ist wirklich ein Top-Access-Point.
Leider braucht man entweder, man kann den administrieren entweder über eine App auf dem Smartphone oder auf dem Tablet.
Oder man muss sich einen UniFi-Controller installieren auf einem Raspberry oder irgendwo anders.
Das ist das einzig Dumme an den Dingern, so ein bisschen, dass die kein eigenständiges Webinterface haben.
Im Gegensatz zu den MikroTik-Dingern.
Brauchst du deinen Minecraft-Server am UniFi-AP?
Ne, da läuft Schraubenstaubsauger.
Verwendest du noch dein Blue Yeti-Microphone?
Äh, wenn ja, hast du ein Audio-Interface?
Ja, habe ich. Also das Blue Yeti steht hier neben mir, verwende ich aber selten.
Ich verwende eigentlich hauptsächlich nur das Mikrofon am MMX300, am Headset.
Weil es halt einfach ist, das habe ich eh schon auf.
Dann wird einfach das Mikro runtergeklappt und aufgenommen.
Ein Audio-Interface habe ich auch.
Ja, einfach aus dem Grund, ich habe so viele Sachen zum Anschließen mittlerweile.
Das Mikro, die Konsolen, die zwei PCs zusammen.
Da habe ich noch ein kleines Mischpult dran.
Als Audio-Interface habe ich das da.
Aber da gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile schon was Neues.
Das Audio-Interface habe ich schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Das da habe ich als Audio-Interface.
War es richtig gut.
Hat massig viele Eingänge.
Ist gut.
Aber gibt mittlerweile bestimmt günstigeres und besseres.
Wie gesagt, das habe ich schon seit, keine Ahnung, acht Jahren oder so.
Ja, WLANs können die meisten Buchhalter.
Ja, WLANs können die meisten Consumer-Dinger nicht.
Da fährst du mit so einem Ubiquiti-Ding schon nicht verkehrt.
Allerdings muss natürlich dein Router auch WLANs können.
Also es reicht nicht, es reicht nicht wirklich, wenn dein Access-Point WLANs kann.
TP-Link.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe auch einen ganz, ganz billigen TP-Link-Access-Point.
Also, den ich davor hatte.
Einen ganz billigen, der kann auch WLANs.
Und das war so ein...
Ein 20-Euro-Ding vor zehn Jahren.
Billiges Crap-Ding, kann auch WLANs.
Die TP-Link-Dinger überraschen mich eh immer wieder, ne?
Die haben zwar meistens ein super hässliches, kompliziertes Webfrontend,
aber Features ist es gar nicht so schlecht.
So ein billig Ding.
Kennst du von MikroTik die PCI-Express DSL?
Nö.
Wusste gar nicht, dass die sowas haben.
Die haben sowas?
Ne, oder? Wie heißt denn das?
Genau, eigenes IoT-Netz.
Würde ich auf jeden Fall machen.
Also generell eigenes Netz für China-Sachen.
Also ich hab's ja bei mir eh so, ich hab zwei unterschiedliche WLANs.
Also eigentlich hab ich sogar drei WLANs.
Eins für alle Tablets und Smartphones, eins für China-Kram, was wieder rein und raus darf irgendwo hin.
Und für Test-Kram.
So, wir sind jetzt 2 Stunden 40 Uhr und ich würde sagen, wir sind wach, oder?
Sind wir wach?
Ne.
War klar.
Also anscheinend sind wir noch nicht wach.
Wir sind noch nicht wach, oder?
Einmal eine Frage zum Pi-Hole.
Das Ding hat echt einen unglücklichen Namen, muss ich sagen, ja?
Pi-Hole.
Ähm, auf diversen Seiten wollen sie, dass man Adblock ausschalten.
Wie sieht das aus, wenn man Pi-Hole hat?
Ähm, kommt auf die Webseite an.
Allerdings ist Pi-Hole eh nicht mehr das, was ich verwenden würde.
Ähm, es gibt leider keine ordentliche Alternative dazu, außer einen Adblocker im Browser,
weil Seiten wie YouTube zum Beispiel liefern mittlerweile die Werbung vom gleichen Server aus wie die Videos.
Das heißt, du kannst mit Pi-Hole nichts mehr blocken.
Twitch macht's ähnlich.
Das heißt, es hilft nur noch ein Adblocker im Browser, wo die große Kacke daran ist,
dass der Adblocker im Browser halt um Desktop gut funktioniert, auf Android teilweise auch,
allerdings auf iOS gibt's sowas nicht.
Also doch, es gibt...
Stimmt nicht.
Es gibt Adblocker für iOS, die funktionieren allerdings nicht in der YouTube- oder in der Twitch-App.
Das ist ein bisschen kacke.
Willst du uns mal deine QoS-Settings zeigen, ey?
Ich kann meinen Router hier nicht aufmachen.
Da sieht man zu viel Zeug drin.
Was benutzt du als Firewall?
Äh, ich benutze das eingebaut, die eingebauten IP-Filter-Sachen in meinen MikroTik-Router.
Ich mein, unter der Haube ist da Nilux drunter mit IP-Tables.
Unter bei den ganzen MikroTik-Dingern.
PS4.
Ja, ist ja ähnlich wie in den Android-Geräten.
Oder in den iOS, das ist halt geschlossen, die Plattform.
Da kannst du keinen Adblocker drauf installieren.
Und es kommt auf die Webseite an, ob die meckern oder nicht.
Ich würde mal sagen, dass die meisten Webseiten mit einem DNS-Blocker nicht meckern,
sondern einfach nicht richtig funktionieren.
Wenn sie nämlich quasi Werbung und Content von der gleichen Domain laden.
Twitch bekommst du gar nicht mehr geblockt, weil es im Stream eingebunden ist.
Doch.
Aber ich will jetzt hier keine Werbung für Twitch-Adblocker machen.
Das wäre irgendwie...
...kontraproduktiv für mich selbst, ja.
Selbst Linus-Techtipps kann ich zaubern.
Pi-Hall funktioniert nicht auf Twitch und YouTube.
Pi-Hall funktioniert auf keinen Seiten, die Content und Werbung von der gleichen Domain ausliefern.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Pi-Hall sorgt dafür, dass manche Domains nicht aufgelöst werden können.
Wenn du jetzt eine Domain hast, wo Content und Werbung von ausgeliefert wird, geht halt der Content nicht.
Und dann ist die Frage, warum gehst du überhaupt auf die Seite?
Das stimmt für Android.
Deswegen sage ich ja bei iOS.
Das ist das Problem.
Für Android ist kein Ding.
Für Android hast du Custom-Apps für YouTube.
Welchen Adblocker origin...
...U-Block-Origin-Beste?
Gibt es für Firefox, für Chrome, wahrscheinlich sogar für Edge.
Sogar für Firefox auf Android.
Mit Prime hast du eh keine Werbung.
Das stimmt nicht.
Prime kriegt ganz normal Werbung, wie jeder andere auch mittlerweile.
Das haben die schon vor einem halben Jahr abgeschafft, dass Prime keine Werbung mehr schaut.
Äh, äh, dass Prime Werbung nicht mehr schaut.
Werbung abschaltet.
Ist nicht mal so.
Mit Prime hast du im ganzen Handy, das stimmt.
Aber Pi-Hole und Twitch geht nicht.
Guckst du hier.
Wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt.
Die liefern von Twitch-TV Content und Werbung aus.
Keine Chance.
Und selbst der Linus kann nichts dagegen tun.
Let's get this out of here.
Wo ist das Video?
Ah.
Okay, look.
I know what you're gonna say.
Linus, why are you showing me how to block ads?
That's how you make money.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob es da irgendwas Neues gibt, was wir noch nicht wussten.
Also wie gesagt, ich wüsste nicht, wie Pi-Hole funktionieren soll mit Twitch und YouTube aktuell.
YouTube weiß ich nicht.
Twitch auf jeden Fall nicht.
And you would be right.
YouTube's AdSense is a big portion of our people,
who would be determined enough to set up something like this,
probably all the time.
So, f*** it.
Today, Pi-Hole, a DNS-based filtering tool,
Das ist immer noch ein ganz normaler DNS-Blocker.
Das kann die Sachen logischerweise nicht filtern,
wenn Content und Werbung von der gleichen Domain kommen.
...figured to block advertisements, tracking and even known malicious sites and malware
on your entire network with this.
Wow, that was a good throw, you almost got me.
A computer so cheap, that I am gonna drop it right now, like a mic.
It's the only one we have.
Speaking of the only one, it's gonna-
Wahrscheinlich hat er das sogar überlebt.
Die Dinger sind relativ robust.
...while, since one of our videos has had just one sponsor, like Smart Deploy.
With Smart Deploy, you don't need any on-site IT from within your web browser.
...with Smart Deploy, you don't need any on-site IT from within your web browser.
They analyze the incoming data sent to your PC when you load a website,
and they remove or replace any content that is recognized as an ad.
Now, this works great for that one browser, or maybe even that whole computer.
But what about ads on devices that don't have or allow ad blocking?
Like the advertisements baked into mobile apps, or on your smart TV,
or even on the Google mobile discover page.
Das stimmt.
Aber Adblocker im Browser funktionieren an Stellen, wo DNS-Adblocker nicht funktionieren können.
Ein Adblocker im Browser kann Twitch und YouTube-Werbung blocken.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ein DNS-Blocker kann das nicht.
So, here's an example.
You launch a mobile game on your phone, and all the assets required by the game start loading.
You got your textures, your dialogue, your music, etc.
Wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt, wollen wir das im nächsten Stream probieren.
Wir probieren das im nächsten Stream aus.
Im nächsten Stream setze ich ein Pi-Hole auf und mache irgendwie Weiterleitungen,
oder wir gucken uns dann an, ob Twitch-Werbung geblockt wird.
Und ich sage euch, es wird nicht geblockt.
Max disst den DNS-Blocker.
Klingt ziemlich aufwendig.
Naja.
Du dd'st ein Image auf eine SD-Karte und startest den Raspberry.
Das war's.
Wir müssen das übrigens noch nicht mal auf dem Raspberry machen.
Wir können das einfach bei mir auf dem Server im Docker machen.
Im Docker-Container starten oder so.
Man kann ja, man kann ja, oder hier, ich kann's in der VM machen.
Ein Pi-Hole installieren, überhaupt kein Problem.
Können wir machen.
Machen wir jetzt.
Easy.
Machen wir nicht im nächsten Stream, machen wir jetzt.
Habe ich überhaupt noch genug Festplattenplatz hier frei?
Oh.
Wir haben keinen Platz mehr.
Warum ist die VM so voll?
OKS.
Was habe ich da alles drauf?
Wir gucken mal.
Was da so viel Speicherverbrauch?
Weil ich sag mal so, 3-4 Gigabyte bräuchte ich schon Platz.
Ja.
Da mal was zu installieren.
Warum ist das so langsam?
Ah fuck.
Das ist so langsam, weil ich die VM nicht auf der SSD, sondern auf der Festplatte liegen habe.
So.
Var ist massig voll.
Cache.
Können wir schon mal alles löschen.
Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Snap ist .NET.
Das ist OK.
Das darf drauf bleiben.
Cache.
Cache kann schon mal alles weg.
Perfekt.
Package.
Ja.
Pack.
Cache.
Alter.
Pack.
Cache.
Minus RK1.
OK.
Wir haben wieder Speicherplatz.
Easy.
OK.
Also.
Starten wir mit Ubuntu 18.04.
Und äh.
Ne.
Moment.
PyHole.
Wie ging das?
Brauchen wir da Debian für?
Brauchen wir da?
Ich zeige euch jetzt, dass es nicht funktioniert.
So.
PyHole.
Das ist das, was die installieren.
So.
Install.
Brauchen wir dann Debian oder geht das auch unter Ubuntu?
Wir machen es ja nicht auf dem Raspberry.
Ich mache es hier in einem Container bei mir lokal.
Äh.
PyHole.
So.
Geht auch unter Ubuntu.
Sehr schön, wenn es unter Ubuntu geht.
Da bin ich.
Bin ich zufrieden.
Hauptsache.
Wichtig.
Wichtig ist, dass die Sachen unter Ubuntu funktionieren.
Unter Ubuntu kann man sich drüber streiten.
Aber Ubuntu ist wichtig.
Wie kannst du so schön.
Zum Beispiel.
Natürlich.
Wie kannst du so schön zwischen PC und VM switchen?
Steuerung.
Alt.
Äh.
jetzt erleben wir das mal. Dann schauen wir mal. Installer will transform your device into a network
wide ad blocker. Okay. Is free. Okay. Is a server that needs static IP address. Okay. Select upstream DNS.
Google. Okay. Manualists. Alles. Bam. IPv6 haben wir gar nicht an, aber auch 10, 49, 33. Oh, ich habe keine globale IP
auf dem Container, aber ist egal. Wir machen es von Linux aus. Yes. IP-Konflikt. Ach so. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Jetzt gucken wir erstmal uns Twitch an und schauen, dass es nicht, ach so, äh, ist
Firefox? Okay. Chrome. Machen Chrome auf, machen Twitch auf. Da werden wir jetzt Werbung kriegen. Es sei denn, ich habe
ja auch einen Adblocker drin. New incognito window. Da gibt es nämlich keinen Adblocker. Twitch. So, wir machen
jetzt irgendwas auf. Hier, Method Starcraft. Da gibt es Werbung.
Oder auch nicht. Ja gut, weil die gerade keine Werbung senden. Wo gibt es denn Werbung? Ich brauche mal einen Channel, wo es Werbung gibt.
YouTube. YouTube gibt es immer Werbung. Da gibt es Werbung. Werbung. Okay, guckt euch an. Immer, immer wenn ich ein Video
aufmache. Also vor allem, wenn ich hier neuen incognito mode aufmache. Ups. Was mache ich denn?
Ich fange mal an und ziehe pra diligently an. Also nochmal, wenn ich hier neuen incognito wie im modus aufmach und gehe auf YouTube dann
gibt es werbung. Okay. Und jetzt stelle ich das auch mal einen Pie Hold ein. Was haben wir für einen IP, da, das Ding hier? Login Passwod, ist, ach
du scheiße. Das kann schon keiner merken. And das da ist das Admin Interface. Okay. Ja. Komplete admin interface. Zack. Da ist, so, Admin Passwod, ist der Admin Passwort?
Admin-Passwort, ist das da?
Login.
Passwort, bam.
Save.
Okay, jetzt stelle ich mal mein DNS.
Achso, das ist natürlich doof.
Ich will mein DNS hier eigentlich gar nicht ändern.
Wohin PowerShell kann SSH?
Ja, mittlerweile kannst du das.
Eigentlich habe ich gar keinen Bock,
mein DNS in meiner VM zu ändern, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Wie mache ich das jetzt am besten?
Weil ich habe das alles ganz gut konfiguriert.
DNS im Browser ändern, geht nicht.
Oder? Kann man mittlerweile DNS im Browser ändern?
Eher nicht.
Wohin ist das jetzt am besten?
Na gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mein Netzwerkzeug hier eingerichtet habe.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Standard-DHCP-Zeug.
Resolve-Conf.
Okay, wir tragen einfach jetzt mal.
Wir tragen jetzt einfach mal temporär das Ding hier ein.
Äh, was ist denn?
So, wir tragen jetzt einfach mal temporär das Ding hier ein.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Server, okay.
Der nimmt den richtigen DNS-Server.
Okay, jetzt probieren wir es aus.
Jetzt sollte ja eigentlich.
Jetzt sollte ja eigentlich keine Werbung mehr auf YouTube kommen,
weil wir jetzt das Pi-Holding verwenden.
Es ist enabled.
Es sind auch zwei Clients registriert,
die das angeblich verwenden.
Ähm, muss man das jetzt noch irgendwie einschalten?
Nee, oder?
Das war's.
Man muss da nichts machen sonst.
Ja.
Wir können unsere Listen updaten noch.
Wie updatet man die Spam-Filter?
Wo ist das nochmal gewesen?
Da?
Update.
Das war auch das neueste haben, ja?
Success.
Okay, wir haben das neueste.
Okay, also machen wir, machen wir einen incognito-Tab auf und gehen auf YouTube.
Wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt der Vorführeffekt.
Es gibt keine Werbung oder so.
Gibt keine Werbung.
Glaube ich aber erst, wenn ich sehe.
Da ist Werbung, guck.
Trotz, trotz Pi-Hold.
Pi-Hold funktioniert nicht mehr für YouTube und Twitch.
Antioxidantien gegen freie Radikale.
Radikale?
Cool.
Wir lieben Lebensmittel.
Deshalb...
Der Pi-Hold ist nur lokal hier erreichbar.
Was ist das für eine Werbung?
Keine Ahnung, EDK oder so.
Also das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Check my Pi-Hold Logs.
Google.
Google Dingsbums.
Wird geblockt.
Google Video.com wird geblockt.
Doubleclick wird geblockt.
Kann man hier suchen?
YouTube.
YouTube wird...
Ja und das ist das Problem.
Wenn die Ads ausliefern.
Wenn die Ads...
Ich sage ja, grün wird nicht geblockt.
So.
Und wenn die jetzt von YouTube.com Content oder halt von...
Ich weiß nicht, von wo die das ausliefern.
CDN oder irgendwie Videos oder so.
Wenn die Content und Werbung von den gleichen Domains ausliefern, machst du halt nichts.
Geht nicht mehr.
Funktioniert nicht.
Twitch funktioniert auch nicht mehr.
Ah.
Müsst gebastelt hier wieder.
Jetzt.
Machen wir die Container aus.
Wieso macht das eigentlich nicht jeder schon lang?
Die Lösung war doch offensivlich.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ähm.
Delete.
Pi-Hold.
Bam.
Also es funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe das...
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich es bei mir abgeschafft habe.
Diese ganze Pi-Hold Geschichte.
Ähm.
Weil erstens, weil es Probleme gemacht hat, bei manchen Seiten das zu laden.
Happy Bird.
Ähm.
Und weil es bei Twitch und YouTube nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ist doch nur da umsetzbar, wo die Seitenbetreiber selbst die Ads ausliefern.
Richtig.
Deswegen funktioniert es ja auch an vielen Stellen noch, wenn es über irgendwelche Ads,
Networks oder sonst was kommt.
Dann funktioniert es natürlich nicht.
Allerdings bei Streaming-Werbung kommt es halt mittlerweile von Twitch oder von YouTube.
Ja.
Jaja.
Es bringt was.
Aber die YouTube-App wird dadurch nicht werbefrei und die Twitch-App wird dadurch auch nicht
werbefrei.
Ja, die normalen Apps, wie gesagt, es funktioniert bei allen, wo die Werbung geladen wird, nicht
von der Domain, wo der Content kommt.
Das ist bei fast allem der Fall.
Aber bei den wichtigsten Sachen für mich, Twitch und YouTube, ist es nicht der Fall.
Deswegen funktioniert dort Pi-Hold nicht.
Einfach YouTube und Twitch über Chromecast schauen, dann hast du nie Werbung.
Das ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Kann man über Chromecast auch Google, Google, auch YouTube browsen oder nur spezielle Videos
angucken?
Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
YouTube Premium.
Ja, das ist ein Grund, warum ich auf Android auch eine Custom YouTube-App verwende.
Weil auf iOS geht mir das so auf den Sack.
Jedes Mal, wenn du die YouTube-App aufmachst, fragt dich das Ding, ob du Premium haben willst.
Jedes Mal.
Oder ob du YouTube Kids haben willst.
Oder ob du YouTube was auch immer haben willst.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, wenn du das hast, dann darfst du auch im Hintergrund Sachen abspielen.
Dann sage ich mir, leck mich am Arsch.
So eine Basis-Funktionalität will ich doch nichts für bezahlen.
Deswegen mache ich YouTube auf iOS immer über Opera auf.
Nicht eingeloggt, weil Opera erlaubt, im Hintergrund Sachen abzuspielen und andere Android-Browser irgendwie nicht.
Bist du dann in der Custom YouTube-App mit Max-FPS angemeldet?
Nö.
Welche Software nutzt du zum Benutzen?
Was betreiben deine VRM auf Windows 10?
VRM bei Workstation.
Alles VRM bei Workstation.
Ich finde es ja auch ein bisschen affig, dass sie die Twitch-App so gebaut haben.
Nicht die Twitch-App, dass sie Twitch Prime so umgebaut haben, dass du wieder Werbung hast.
Opera GX, das war der Gaming-Browser, ne?
Ne, Hyper-V ist nicht das Beste.
Hyper-V ist für Desktop-Virtualisierung garantiert nicht das Beste.
Ich habe mir VRM-Werke gekauft.
Die haben an Weihnachten immer ganz gute Angebote.
Normalerweise kostet es, glaube ich, 140 Euro oder so.
Ja, die haben es ein bisschen umbenannt.
Früher war Player kostenlos in Workstation.
An Weihnachten haben die meistens ganz gute Aktionen.
Da gibt es das teilweise eben für 40 Euro oder sowas.
Gucken wir mal, was kostet es denn auf Amazon?
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
Das sieht nach übelstem Crap aus.
Ha, Windows XP!
Lul, was ist das?
Okay, nichts, was ich verwenden würde.
Gibt es nicht zu kaufen.
Der Fenstertitel ist Virtual Box, ernsthaft?
Die verkaufen einfach Virtual Box.
Kack-Noobs.
Keine Ahnung, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir sogar noch was Sinnvolles gemacht.
Ich werde mir jetzt bei Fiverr die Leute raussuchen und anschreiben.
Moment, wo habe ich die Datei überhaupt gespeichert?
Die Datei habe ich ein bisschen am falschen Ort.
Explorer?
Wie startet man hier was?
Da hat es überhaupt nichts dran zu suchen.
Ich will das nicht demnächst auf GitHub pushen.
Okay, dann schicke ich den Leuten auf Fiverr jetzt mal das Zeug.
Dann gucken wir mal, was wir da für tolle Anwendungen kriegen.
Kannst du mir einen Switch empfehlen?
Mit 8-10 Ports.
Wenn du nichts spezielles brauchst, hol den billigsten bei Amazon.
Den billigsten unmanaged Switch auf Amazon.
Hol dir irgendeinen TP-Link oder sonst was.
Wenn du wirklich nichts damit spezielles machen willst,
außer einfach nur Geräte anschließen,
hol den billigsten von Amazon, den du findest mit genug Ports.
Da sage ich nichts falsch machen.
Wenn du bissel mehr machen willst, würde ich mir einen Mikrotik Switch holen.
Die sind auch relativ günstig und haben halt richtig gute Features.
Wahrscheinlich brauchst du die gar nicht.
Du willst wahrscheinlich nur Geräte anschließen und benutzen.
Dann hol dir den billigsten von Amazon, und gut, es ist wie ein TP-Link oder so etwas.
Oder mal wie ein Netgear.
Der Switch sollte schon 1GB haben.
Zeig mir mal einen Switch der heutzutage nicht Gigabit Ports hat.
Das würde ich gar nicht mehr erwähnen.
Gibt es wirklich noch
Switche, die keine...
Pfff, ernsthaft?
Ach du Scheiße.
Hehehe, lol.
Na gut,
okay, hol dir den billigsten
Gigabit-Switch.
Für 14,90 oder so.
Oder hier, 12-Port.
Billigste 12-Port-Switch.
Kostet hier 54.
Was ist...
Da muss ich mal gucken, was hat ein MikroTik
so zu bieten?
In, ähm, 12-Port-Switches.
Die kleinen, die kleinen haben nämlich alle immer
nur 5.
Hier, 8.
Ja, der kostet schon 140.
Und der 24er kostet natürlich ähnlich viel,
ja.
Lohnt sich nicht. Hol dir den billigen bei Amazon.
Ja.
TP-Link.
Oder Netgear oder sowas.
Ja.
8 Ports, guck mal.
8 Ports, Gigabit-Switch, 22 Euro.
Da kann man doch nix machen.
Ja, ja, ja. Amazon-Startseite.
Easy as fuck.
So, Leute, ähm.
Machen wir Schluss.
Ähm, Musik ist auch aus.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream oder im nächsten Video.
Bis dann.
CU.
PP-Hands, ja.
Weiß, ganz tragisch.
Bis dann. Tschüss.